side of the International Space Station
for a spacewalk
NASA astronaut Nicole Mann and Japanese
astronaut kuichiwakata are our space
Walkers today and their goal is to
install some Hardware to the outside of
the space station to prepare for the
future installment of irosas or ISS
rollout solar arrays and we'll get into
a little bit more about what those are
in just a minute
but this spacewalk is part of an ongoing
effort to upgrade the Space Station's
power system
today's space walk focuses on installing
a support structure that a future solar
array can be attached to in the future
the support structure is made up of six
struts and a mounting bracket but
remember no actual solar rays are going
to be put on today
the spacewalk is a continuation or a
part two spacewalk for man and wakada
they began work to install this Hardware
on Friday January 20th and are set to
complete the job today over the course
of a spacewalk that could last up to
seven hours
this includes finishing up some work on
the lower strut and installing the mid
strut I'll also be doing some get ahead
tasks if time allows
these are our space Walkers Nicole Mann
sometimes you'll hear her referred to as
duke she's got the spacesuit with the
red stripes she'll be our ev1 today and
koichi rukwata from the Japanese
Aerospace Exploration Agency is our ev2
today he's in the suit with the with no
stripes
so we are in the quest airlock aboard
the International Space Station that's
where these live views are coming from
Quest consists of two parts the
equipment lock and the crew lock
they're in the process of moving our
space Walkers over to the crew lock
where depressurization will take place
but this view you're getting right now
is in the equipment lock that's NASA
astronaut Frank Rubio and the bluish
black shirt and the glass is there to
your right
that's NASA astronaut Josh cassida in
the Red Flannel the long sleeves on your
screen now
he's helping get our spacewalker suited
up with the safer unit so their
spacesuits are on and now he's
installing this sort of backpack so
stands for simplified aid for Eva rescue
we don't plan on using this backpack
during the spacewalk but in the unlikely
event that they become untethered or
unattached to the space station any way
they can use these safers to get
themselves back
our space Walkers are running about 35
minutes ahead of schedule today and we
expect depressurization to begin about
five minutes past the hour
shortly before our live coverage began
the spacewalkers got into their suits
and began what's known as their
pre-breathing exercise this is a way for
the astronauts to avoid decompression
sickness something that scuba divers
have to be careful of as well
they put on masks and began to breathe
pure oxygen and also completed a series
of arm and leg exercises to purge their
bodies of nitrogen
decompression sickness can happen when
gases like nitrogen in our body form
bubbles in our blood and tissues so
these preventative measures like
breathing through oxygen and the
exercise are critical before spacewalk
so these were already completed before
our coverage began today
so you could see NASA astronaut Frank
Rubio not in the spacesuit on the left
of your screen there he's what's known
as a suit IV the name is referring to a
crew member who's responsible for
getting
through the procedures to safely get the
spacewalkers out on their way out the
door this includes helping the
spacewalker put their spacesuit on
recording the status of the suit and
getting them ready for depressurization
right now he's assisting our spacewalker
the one inside the spacesuit NASA
astronaut Nicole Mann
so in addition to Nicole Mann or Duke as
her call sign is you may sometimes refer
heartbeat hear her referred to as duke
you'll see her in the suit with the red
stripes but another way that you can
tell is that our two spacewalkers are
from two different nations so you see
that Napoleon has the American flag on
hers while kuichiwakata has the Japanese
flag on his
you can see NASA astronaut Josh cassida
and the red shirt in the crew lock
section of the quest airlock he's also
known as a student IV as well again
assisting our spacewalkers get out the
door today
you may hurt hear Nicole Mann or Duke
referred to as ev1 that means she's
responsible for operating the hatch and
its thermal cover once depressurization
is complete and the spacewalkers are
ready to head out you may see live views
of a door swinging open and that's
Nicole man in the red stripe suit making
that happen she'll be the first to exit
the airlock followed shortly by
kuichiwakata
both spacewalkers now in the crew lock
after they get configured in there with
the help of our suit IVs that door will
close and will only have views of
our student IVs Frank Rubio and Josh
cassida and then here in Mission Control
Houston we'll do a go no-go Poll for
depressurization
you're watching live coverage of our
space walk today this is part two of us
spacewalk 84 that happened on January
20th but even though it's a continuation
it is indeed called U.S spacewalk 85
this morning this of course would make
it the second spacewalk for NASA
astronaut Nicole man and Japanese
astronaut koichiwakata
you're getting a live view now of
Mission Control Houston the space
station is handing over Communications
between its satellites and as a result
we've lost our live video and audio feed
just for a moment
these communication handovers are
planned and expected and we should get
our live views back shortly
in the meantime we do have a live view
of Mission Control Houston
our flight director oversees everyone in
this room and our support rooms that
aren't shown right now she gathers Intel
from all of the experts and ultimately
makes the decision on how to move
forward
and there she is popping into screen
briefly on the lower right of your
screen our flight director today is
Chloe Maring she's a Pennsylvania native
who began her career at Nasa in 20 2008.
but on your screen
uh we have NASA astronaut Xena Cardman
who's our ground IV today there she is
in the black jacket sitting down mid
screen
this is a similar role to a Capcom
communicating from the grounds to the
astronauts on one we're putting on the
final touches here putting them into the
airlock and can you confirm again that
they are not yet hot bikes
good morning increment 68 this is Drew
on console with Xena we can confirm the
crew is not hot Mike yet and looking
forward to working with you guys today
sounds great looking forward to working
with you guys as well and you'll be
hearing from these guys as soon as you
do make them hot like
so that was Josh cassida confirming that
we're not able to hear the spacewalkers
right now they've not yet turned on
these microphones it's one of the steps
in their procedures haven't accomplished
it quite yet but they're moving down the
checklist
and NASA astronaut Xena Cardman is who
will be communicating with our space
Walkers out on their spacewalk today
outside of the International Space
Station
so while we wait for depressurization to
begin let's talk a little bit about the
irosas these are roll out solar arrays i
i s s r o roll out an s a solar array
irosa
they're attached to support structures
and are unfurled the same way you'd roll
out a rug
they're not designed to replace the
Space Station's Legacy arrays but rather
to add the power add power to the Legacy
arrays that they already provide they
are unraveled over the top of the
station's rigid Legacy arrays and even
though they're partially blocking these
Legacy arrays from the Sun the irises
are so efficient that it actually
results in more power generation for the
station
so the space station has eight power
channels I'm going to list them for you
here they're 1A 1B 2A 2B 3A 3B and 4A
and 4B so four of the eight power
channels already have the irosas roll
out solaries already installed but every
Arosa needs to be paired with a support
structure with a mounting bracket on it
so that it can be properly installed to
the space station
during the January 20th spacewalk wakata
and man installed the mounting bracket
on the 1B power Channel you see that on
the left of your screen
they moved on to work on the 1A Channel
but ran into some difficulty during the
installation
teams here on the grounds have
communicated some possible solutions
some troubleshooting items with our
space Walkers and they're heading out
the door today to give them a try and
finish the installation remember no
solar rays are being installed today
we're just getting the hardware in place
so that they can be installed in the
future
so to recap four power channels are
completed with support structures and
solar arrays they're done
a fifth support structure was completed
earlier this month and today our space
Walkers are installing the sixth and in
the future these two structures will
have solar arrays on them too
and NASA astronaut Josh cassida in the
red flannel shirt has just exited the
crew lock having situated our space
Walkers today and has moved back over to
the equipment lock
he and NASA astronaut Frank Rubio on the
left of your screen there are going
through a list of procedures to get
these spacewalkers ready for
depressurization that has not begun yet
but we expect it pretty soon
you're not hearing anything right now
and that's pretty normal our
spacewalkers have not yet turned on
their microphones into a configuration
that will be able to hear them but we
should be able to hear their voices as
well as the voices of our suit IVs Frank
Rubio and Josh Castle are pretty shortly
and the hatch is now closed our
spacewalkers are on the other side of
the door with that window there
right now the crew lock and the
equipment lock are roughly the same PSI
a space station is kept around 14.7 or
what you'd experience around sea level
here on Earth that's what your body
would experience
once depressurization begins they're
going to slowly bring the crew lock so
the other side of the door down to
vacuum they're going to slowly decrease
the pressure and then they're going to
stop when it hits about 5 PSI to do a
check on the spacesuits make sure that
there's no leaks and everything's in a
good configuration
and with the go here in Mission Control
they're going to continue on to go down
to vacuum
distance
76 and 77 are complete
hey like Houston copies we've got uh 78
in work you guys will be picking up in
step 80.
okay and uh Drew if you guys can uh also
take
79 and 80 decimal one and just let us
know when the crew is how much
yeah we got that in work as well and uh
so in short order crew will be hot might
thanks
okay thank you okay thank you
and crew lock Houston you are hot Mike
he needs to copy
and we just heard the voices of our
spacewalkers today for the first time
NASA astronaut Nicole Mann our ev1 as
she just referred to herself and ev2
kuichiwakata
foreign
[Music]
step 84.
foreign
Houston uh team's ready here your go-to
start uh work in the Deep rescue card we
got two minutes to hand over
coffee go and understand three minutes
handle thanks for
okay guys we are going to get started on
the cool rock paper
busy first step is for you
[Applause]
is on now
open TV
okay defense top Daniel ISO valve open
and for both of you
um
shoot pressure gauge and then it remains
below five decimal five
you're hearing NASA astronaut Frank
Rubio communicating with our space
Walkers Nicole Mann and koichiwakata who
were just on the other side of the door
with the window right there
depressurization has begun with a go for
Mission Control Houston
down to five decimal zero when we hit
six decimals you can both expect our
tone
coffee
so as depressurization is underway
aboard the International Space Station
we're in a brief Handover of our
communication satellites
we expect to get our live views back
shortly meanwhile let me talk about some
key figures here in the room uh NASA
astronaut Xena Cardman is our ground IV
today this is a similar role to Capcom
but she'll specifically be talking to
the astronauts outside of the space
station
she joined our astronaut Corps in 2017
and another key member here in Mission
Control is our spacewalk officer Keith
Johnson he knows the ins and outs of the
spacewalks of the spacewalk all of the
steps that the crew needs to complete
and he consults with his team throughout
the Spaceball at any real-time decisions
that need to be made
we're back with our live views of the
International Space Station
the crew lock is just above 10 psi
making its way down to five
ah
this depressurization process can take
some time
so while that happens we're going to do
a little rundown of today's tasks
write out the Starting Gate they'll turn
on their hekas which are high definition
cameras sometimes we'll be able to see
views from their point of view
they'll grab all of their supplies and
tools that they need and make their way
over to the work site on the 1A power
channel to setup shop
here at the 1A work site they'll find
most of the completed support structure
that looks like a pyramid
they built this during their last
spacewalk earlier this month
it's almost complete
the sounds that you're hearing now from
your screen is normal and as part of the
depressurization process that just means
everything's underway
foreign
spacewalkers are at their 1A power
Channel work site today they'll be at
this support structure that they've
built during their last spacewalk
then they're going to do some
troubleshooting on the parts of the
structure that gave them some trouble
during the last installation and finish
up their work
then we'll move on to some other tasks
to help our space walkers in the future
Nicole Mann will route some cables
needed when the solar arrays are
installed she won't plug them in but
she'll follow a path to get the cables
to where they need to go
and while Nicole Mann routes these
cables koichiwakata will swap out a
sticky portable foot restraint for a
smoother one and Nicole man will join
him at the end of this task also
relocating a portable foot restraint
just to bring it closer for future
spacewalks
ah fast
foreign
the pressure in the suit lock has
reached 6 PSI slowly going down to five
at which point they'll do a leak check
on these spacesuits and then proceed
down to vacuum
all right guys we're coming up on five
PSI koichi the next section will be for
you
all right
man ISO valve is closed you can both
expect another time okay different from
Daniel ISO valve closed
okay next you're both going to be
performing a leak check so switch
display you're going to go to status I'm
sorry you see a leak check question mark
displayed and then you'll have a long
yes to select
check
okay we check uh selected and just
follow the displayed instructions let me
know when you're complete
check complete if you want leave check
complete
for both of you check go through
actuator Eva
didn't work
foreign
ah
emergency Empire is open you can both
monitor your two pressure gauge make
sure you remain below five decimal five
from here we'll be depressing to two
decimal zero before our next action
so the crew lock which is just behind
the door with the window there started
out at 14.7 PSI same as the rest of the
International Space Station it has gone
down to 5 PSI where we went through a
expected pause in the depressurization
to check for leaks seeing none we've
continued on with the depressurization
and the PSI sits at about four going
down to vacuum
foreign
if you're just joining us this morning
we're in live coverage of a spacewalk
they have not made it out the door yet
but are expected too soon what you're
seeing on your screen now is not
actually our space walkers
these are NASA astronauts Frank Rubio on
the right and Josh cassida on the left
looking into the window there just on
the other side of the door are our space
walkers donned in their spacesuits
they're getting ready to go out the door
after the pressure has gone down to
vacuum
the spacewalk has not officially started
yet but after it does and our
spacewalkers have gone out of the hatch
they plan to make their way over to the
1A work site where they're going to
finish up construction of a support
structure that will one day house a
irosa or ISS roll out solar array
okay guys we're coming up on two PSI
koichi the next action will be for you
puppy
thank you different from manners of our
phones
if there's some man united that I'm
close
copy foreign
power offs
okay and with that I will turn you over
to Xena for your initial antenna config
godspeed you guys are going to crush it
awesome thank you Frank and Josh
you guys are awesome
hello ev1 and ev2 your ground IV and the
whole ground team are here ready for
your tether checks
starting with ev1 let's start with my
left waist cutter is attached to my
Rocky ring extender his clothes slide as
well
back on black
by Safety Center
disconnected through my right d-ring
extender
Red Hook is closed
and there's lots of black on black
yellow hook
detach the green reel this course slider
blocks black on black
green Hook is attached the red reader
real
it's closed and it is unlocked
both my reels are unlocked
I have my anchor to my mini workstations
by RightWay setter
just connected to my right viewing
extender is for sliders log on black
and if you have eyes on your anchor hook
to my weight setter
your
right weight Center on both hooks deep
closed hook lock of luck
okay uh you need to
buy left weight feather is attached to
the they have experience when the gate
close to clock
the small hook of my left weight Center
is attached to my left giving a kiss in
there okay close the clock it's like a
buck
a Red Hook is attached to my left
gearing extender state closer blocked
like come back
yellow Hook is attached to the green
reel gate close
is attached to the red
heel gate closed Hook is unlocked
and then the anger because attached to
they report it to Dukes
makes it better
on my right side like legs that are
looking attached to my uh
during the time to get closed
before complete
koichi if I could just check that your
reels are both unlocked
copy all ev1 and ev2 that's a good
config for both of you
all right continuing along with our
depress here when the crew lock dpdt is
approximately zero you can both expect
an alert tone
two copies
you just heard the voice of our ground
IV NASA astronaut Xena Cardman
communicating with our space Walkers
he'll be hearing her voice a lot more as
our spacewalkers get out the door today
they just went through the configuration
of their Hooks and tethers
it's very essential to stay attached to
the International Space Station while
they're maneuvering all around to their
different work sites retrieving the
portable foot restraints that are in
their tasks today moving out to the 1A
work site it's important that they get
all of their hooks configured not
Tangled and in a way that they're able
to move freely and so that's what our
ground IVs in a cardmen was
going through with them and it looks
like everything is in a good
configuration
ah
depressurization is still underway in
the crew lock we're sitting at about one
PSI going down to vacuum doesn't exactly
have to be 0.0 but they are going down
maybe around 0.5 or so in the meantime
let's talk let's introduce our
spacewalkers today
NASA astronaut Nicole Mann is our ev1 in
the suit with the red stripes you may
hear her referred to as duke
and we have koichi wakata from Japan
this is his second space walks same as
Nicole Mann they both
went on a spacewalk on January 20th to
begin the installation on this mod kit
so to speak it's what the future solar
arrays are going to sit on
so this is their second spacewalk
continuing that tasks their first one
lasted seven hours and 21 minutes
and the spacewalk is the
259th spacewalk in support of space
station assembly maintenance and
upgrades and these six spacewalk of
expedition 68.
ah
we expect depressurization to be done in
less than 10 minutes going from the
original pressure of the International
Space Station 14.7 down to five when
they did their uh suit check make sure
that there's not any leaks in there it
went pretty quickly but when we're going
from five down to vacuum the process is
a little bit more deliberate more
careful we want to make sure our space
Walkers are healthy and ready for their
spacewalk so we do move a little slower
the crew lock is about 0.8 PSI going
down a vacuum
we expect NASA astronaut Nicole Mann to
be the first out the door today
she'll be followed shortly after by
kuichiwakata but before koichi wakada
fully egresses or exits the airlock
he'll be handing some equipment to
Nicole man that they'll need on today's
spacewalk this includes the mid-strut
remember that they've already completed
most of the structure that they're
building today but they didn't complete
the mid strut
excuse me they didn't complete the mid
strut so they're taking that out with
them to their work site so wakata will
hand man the mid strut he'll also hand
her over a cable bag that they might
need later in the spacewalk and then he
himself will egress or exit the space
station
foreign
ah
we're getting close to a PSI of 0.5
which means you'll begin to hear some
chatter from our suit IVs that you see
on screen there NASA astronaut Josh
cassida on the left and that's astronaut
Frank rubia on the right with more
instructions for our spacewalkers
oh
NASA astronaut Frank Rubio there
patiently waiting as the pressure gets
down to 0.5 PSI demonstrating the
effects of living in microgravity
crew we are less than 0.5 PSI you are go
to open the EV hatch and Stow
it was
Mission Control has given the go to open
the hatch
[Applause]
thank you
and with the go from Mission Control our
spacewalkers have released a valve that
opens up the outer thermal cover
yeah I'm also rolled
shortly after this thermal cover is
popped open then the hatch itself the
actual door they egress out of will open
and I come down so I can get it latched
here okay
let's see if you're like little feet I'm
going to come back
okay the hatch is open and in the
hatchkey
hatches open and Josh and Frank you can
take the emergency empath closed
emergency Tampa quote
copy Frank okay crew on your DCM switch
power to bat stagger your switch throws
expect a warning tone
batteries
okay
One battery
copy both in battery switch your display
to Pro to verify a functional display
great news on the UIA switch power for
ev1 and 2 off
by a or eb1
mpd2 both off four LEDs are off copy
four LEDs are off disconnect SCU from
DCM
and you heard our ground IV today NASA
astronaut xenocardman here in mission
control with us talking to our space
Walkers just on the other side of the
door that you see there with the window
walking them through some of their
procedures before they get out the door
one of them being turning their
spacesuits onto battery power which
marks the official start of the
spacewalk and both spacesuits have been
switched to battery power
okay for easy one SEO is disconnected
third in the pouch and the velcro is
tight
copy ev1 you can also install your DCM
cover
is these young peppers and salt the easy
one
82 this is disconnected and stored in
the pouch and the DCM cover is a
okay copy you both have your seus stowed
with DCM covers installed
check depressed pump man ISO valve
closed
take your tcv max hot
didn't work
and now that our spacewalkers have
turned their suits onto battery power we
have an official spacewalk start time of
6 45 a.m Central Time 7 45 a.m Eastern
the spacewalk is expected to last up to
seven hours to complete installation of
a mounting bracket that will one day
house an irosa or ISS roll out solar
array in support of giving the space
station a power upgrade
32 microphone
Copy Max hot
switch water on
water's on for easy one
coffee water on for you both check your
DCM is blank and bite is off
easy words
and bite off eating YouTube
okay take your tcv set as desired
reminder report to MCC all subsequent
tcv changes
copy five and seven okay report your
suit P gauge to MCC
1 4.2
copy four decimal two and four decimal
three set your visors as required you'll
be coming out into a day pass
es
down five
uh
as our ground IV NASA astronaut
xenocarbon just relayed up to our space
Walkers the International Space Station
is in an orbital daytime
space station is currently over the
South Pacific Ocean
and it's nice and lit as our
spacewalkers get out the door today
okay with that ev1 you are ready to open
the hatch thermal cover
release the hook from the magnetic plate
d-ring attach the hook to the stowage
tether point and cinch the strap until
it's snug with six lines visible
our space walkers have completed steps
with our ground IV that they have to do
after depressurization
and NASA astronaut Nicole Mann is
opening the thermal hatch cover as part
of her responsibilities as ev1 today you
can see the motion in the dead center of
your screen
okay uh the thermal cover book is set
stone and six lines are visible
copy Duke you are go to open that
thermal cover egress the airlock and
turn on your hekka
okay criminal cover is open and I'm
interesting
the hatch is open and with the go from
Mission Control Houston Ness astronaut
Nicole Manor ev1 is egressing or exiting
the airlock to begin her second
spacewalk that began at 6 45 a.m Central
Time
1081 is out of airlock
great work Duke you can turn on your
heka Ichi you'll get the midstart ready
to transfer to ev1
it's on for easy one okay uh you need to
copy send you can you see the uh
okay on standby okay
NASA astronaut Nicole man has exited the
airlock you can see her on your screen
in the suit with the red stripes around
her thighs okay
koichiwakata is going to now Hampshire
some equipment that they'll need during
the course of their spacewalk
you might hear some chatter about
turning on their hekas this is one of
the steps in their procedures
we may occasionally get views from their
point of view Nicole Mann 's helmet
camera would be listed as number 22 you
might see that number burned into some
of the screens that means we're looking
at her point of view okay
okay all right for the missile I'm
releasing the airlock Road okay
it's coming back to you okay copy that I
see that
we're in a brief hand over here in
mission control but we expect to get our
live views of our space Walkers back
soon
your next steps once you've got that
right
will be to transfer the cable bags
okay
so while we were in that Handover NASA
astronaut koichiwakata just handed
Nicole man uh what she's holding there
that's the mid strut that they'll need
to install later today he's in the
process of handing her a cable bag that
they'll be using towards the end of the
spacewalk now
she noted that she'll be stowing the mid
strut on her brt that's what she's
working on that refers to the body
restraint tether like we talked about
earlier they've got a number of tethers
and hooks to attach themselves and their
equipment to the space station so it
doesn't float away
here
okay we see us I'm ready for the cable
back okay here comes the cable bag okay
I see it
and I
okay you had a consult hey you still
read it okay the uh right down to the
airlock okay okay
um
the cable bag
hey people back
that's released
okay with that thing I can
give it to you also
hey from koichi you can egress the
airlock turn on your hekka and receive
that cable bag from Duke
has successfully handed both the mid
strut and the cable bag over to Nicole
Mann he's set to egress or exit the
International Space Station and take
that cable bag back from Nicole man as
soon as he's out
all right
we're not actually installing these
cables today on today's spacewalk but
rather these are some get ahead tasks
that they can do to help future space
Walkers get the cables where they need
to go without actually plugging them in
making sure they're not Tangled and out
of the way
um
you're running okay
let me check that
looks like umbilical is loaded around
[Applause]
it's like the umbilical is routed around
the uh Safety Center
so let me uh
if that's the uh
Festival of the uh
umbilical and then uh heads up for
koichi yeah
there is a small small rat floating free
in the airlock
ah
and Gucci it's IV hatch Zenith if you
get eyes on
it
[Applause]
foreign
from
checking
with me
I have my uh my two Reds with me as well
okay copy it as long as you both have
your brt reps and all of your expected
rets on your mini workstation koichi you
can secure that ret in the airlock if
you prefer you can also take it out with
you
Okay I uh
unless there's a need for that
I will keep I will throw this in the
airlock
Luigi we recommend actually bringing it
with you if you want to attach it to
your mini workstation or to a bag
okay
okay that's complete and then I'm gonna
clear the
umbilical
NASA astronaut Nicole man is there in
the upper middle of your screen in the
spacesuit with the red stripes she's
carrying some equipment with her
Japanese astronaut koichiwakada is still
in the airlock working his way on
getting all of the equipment that he
needs and working on egressing or
exiting the airlock
okay umbilical is now clear
job quiche and just let us know if
you're grabbing that red and taking it
with you
I guess I'm not taking that the Reds
with me
the uh
see you
on today a lot
so uh
okay copy and did you just stash the red
on your mini Workstation
perfect thanks so much
okay no problem coming out
okay I'm still attached
private
I got it thank you
we're getting a view of the spacewalk
from NASA astronaut Nicole man's point
of view as konichiwakada exits the
airlock
starting to get some Earth views as well
from her point of view the International
Space Station is flying over Chile at
the moment
hey I am
to the people there
and then VIP the Joe's close
I'm gonna turn on the factor right now
okay
I see if I can green LED on now
so uh yeah I think you can pickle like
yeah
okay thank you really thank you
okada now receiving the cable bag he had
initially handed it to Nicole Manchester
great is now taking it back config
outside the airlock
koichi will get your hekka turned on I
think you did already and then we'll
take Buddy checks
okay
two green lights for you I see your
helmet lights on I've got one two and
then I see your right in front of your
right bathroom I just flip your camera
up a little bit okay I got one two three
tapped up yes
baseball handle your left one is down
uh your right one can you move your PPT
out
it's uh that one looks like it's up a
little bit if you push down on your
right paper handle
ah
it's fully down could you verify yep
okay both your safer handles are down
okay I see the bag on your pit and I see
all of our feathers in front of us they
look good okay I'll check yours
I see ya
thicker LED it's called WDS LEDs on
students
up here at the services
see your left right safer handle and
then
I suppose the paper handles are down
feather is good and then I see the
midstret and uh it's good okay
copy you both that's a good check we'll
take a baseline half as well
okay I got a drive they find half for
anyone
it has the same driving
and stand by for you both we may have
you just check koichi's safer handled
door check that the door did not
actually come open
okay
for the door
um is closed on his safer
let me know if you need a uh if you have
a good view in the hacker
okay Duke and Gucci we copy that we
trust your eyes on and with that
Duke you can translate to the Anchor
location that's at the S1 S3 interface
just below the starboard seated cart as
you start translating just a couple
cautions avoid contact with radiators
and flex hoses and don't contact the
toss cables
and after completing their buddy checks
they are off onto their work sites
during these buddy checks kuichiwakata
and Nicole man checked out their
counterparts made sure that the green
lights were on on their cameras as well
as some others they also checked out
their safer handles member safer we
talked about earlier in the coverage
safer being the simplified aid for Eva
rescue that's these backpacks they're
wearing on their backs
in the unlikely event that they're
separated from the space station like
these safers can get them back okay copy
that
in the unlikely event that they do get
separated from the space station there's
a button that deploys handles that
control these safers
and it's easy to accidentally push this
button so they were just discussing and
making sure that these handles are in
fact down on both boxes both
spacewalkers and we confirm that they
are and so now they're off to their work
site
and koichi if you could also attend the
hatch thermal cover clothes that would
help us a lot
yeah it worked
okay I'm putting a four-man spray later
at the top of the Petersburg okay great
thank you
you're getting the point of view of
Japanese astronaut koichiwakata as he
works to close the thermal hatch cover
meanwhile Nicole Mann is off to her work
site you may have heard them discuss the
S1 S3 in terms of orientation of the
space station this refers to the
starboard side
of course in space it's It's tricky to
find your way around so they do use
starboard important just like on a ship
being on that mile marker Duke
it'll be right at the S1 S3 interface
I'll get you a mile marker
okay
so S1 is pretty close to the center of
the space station and when you get more
towards the outer edges they refer to
that as the S6
and Duke looks like
so for the mile marker
this is the point of view of NASA
astronaut Nicole Mann
Japanese astronaut kuichiwakata is still
at the airlock he'll join her shortly
copy Duke you'll attach your ev1 anchor
hook to S1 handrail 32-17
and that's the smaller diagonal one
okay
everyone anchor Hook is attached to
32-17 it's closed Fighters lost black on
black
copy Duke you can now attach koichi's
ev2 anchor hook to S3 handrail 3011
that's the slightly longer vertical
handrail
now that both suppose now that both
spacewalkers are outside of the hatch
they're working on setting up their work
sites Nicole man making her way over and
setting up some anchor hooks you may
hear about these anchor hooks throughout
our coverage
it has to do with moving around the
space station and configuring your
tethers
you could kind of think of it sort of
like rock wall climbing if you're
familiar you have to you have your
anchor right at the top and you have
your rope supporting you you're free to
move left right up and down but your
anchor hook stays the same
part of their task today is to relocate
some of these anchor hooks a little
later
these anchors connected to 3011
copy Duke
and standby crew koichi we're seeing
your safer door is actually popping open
we'll get words to you in just a moment
foreign
we actually recommend that Duke head
back to the airlock to help koichi with
that safer door
you can leave the anchor hooks where
they are
and Duke head back to the airlock
okay
Japanese astronaut koichiwakata here at
the airlock the center of your screen
working on closing the hatched
just the door is partially open and so I
think if we have Duke translate back to
you to help get that door closed again
that'll be better than having us
possibly have that become even more open
and actually deploy the safer
okay that sounds good
yeah okay
it looks like the uh
a fairly is uh
it's like a house right right yeah right
let's see what's done on the cedar sport
right at the very top of it like right
below okay
let's go back to the point of view of
NASA astronaut Nicole man she's heading
back to koichiwakata who is at the
airlock working on closing the hatch
door
part of koichiwakata's safer unit that
backpack that he wears on his back is
popped open it's really difficult to
reach behind you in these spacesuits so
Nicole man is making her way back to
help him pop that back into place
and koichi while you're there you can
release your waste tether from the
airlock d-ring extender and close that
thermal cover
puppy that's teamwork
okay let's wait till I
is now closed
okay copy
it looks like that says he said it did
not hold at the top of the feet of spur
but it's clear for me now though it is
station sponsored
coming down to see this Mercury see okay
us
Nicole man now re-entering your frame on
the left side of the screen she is now
with koichiwakata at the airlock
orientation
um
hey Duke your feet are caught on
koichi's safety tether just watch out
there they're currently behind your
calves
okay now it's clear
okay
and
let me get a local bounce weekend and
then I'll have you getting a good
thing over here and just some words for
you guys as you're getting set up a
reminder there's a pin for that safer
handle door the safer door that's going
to have to go back into a hole and so I
would recommend that Duke you hold the
door closed
pull up slightly on that safer handle
and then fully close the door and try to
reseat the handle in order to get that
handle back in the PIN
can you go on your bathroom this is a
little more close to me
okay that's good okay
the safer unit is in the center of your
screen there so you see the American
flag NASA logo behind it we have the
safer unit that's not designed for use
during the spacewalk but in the unlikely
event that they get untethered they can
use this device to get them back to the
space station kuichi's wakada
kuichiwakatas is being a little sticky
so Nicole Mann is assisting get it into
the right configuration
okay yeah it was like the tiniest bit
out it pushed it uh pulled up and then
down and I felt it quick in and now it
looks um
totally flush
Nicole man's point of view now if we're
checking in your heck of views it sounds
like a good config thanks so much
thank you duke yeah
okay and it might be your safety feather
is
in front of my life
in front of your bed okay perfect and
yours will keep it off tonight
okay all right
hey firm Duke you can head back out and
then koichi since your uh anchor hooks
are all set up out there you can follow
Duke just keep a little bit of distance
try to distance with those safety
tethers
I'll be back yeah that's the way till I
get past our anchors like or I don't
know as long as you can just keep an eye
on that squeezy okay
do that
all right Christian
okay I'll follow you
ass
ES
and with that both of our spacewalkers
are out on their way to the work site
this worksite being the 1A power channel
on the International Space Station where
they're completing their work installing
a support structure a mod kit if you
will
okay I'm coming up on the theater right
now they see your face each other
okay
[Applause]
this work site that they're heading out
to they'll find
okay yep
us
out at their work site at the 1A power
Channel they'll find a structure kind of
similar to a pyramid that one day the
irosis rollout solar arrays will rest on
they're almost completed with it
but not quite done what you're seeing on
your screen now is a visual of the mod
kit that they're finishing up today it's
made up of six struts and one mounting
bracket where the solar array will go
that's in the blue
of course the real thing's not colorful
like our graphic here but for the safe
sake of explaining uh check out the pink
upper triangle and the blue mounting
bracket these are already complete your
S4 work site before on the bottom in the
gray you'll see the lower strut it's
installed but it needs the lower bolt on
the left lower strut to be checked out
they'll need to troubleshoot on that
bottom bolt to finish the job and then
the Orange Line in the center of the
graphic is the mid strut and today
they'll need to completely install the
mid strut and that's what Nicole man is
carrying with her
while troubleshooting this lower strut
they'll need to make sure that there's
no gap between the strut and the
physical bearing
they'll essentially want to confirm that
the two pieces they've connected are
flush and not angled with an uneven Gap
they'll also do a wiggle test on the
same piece of Hardware to make sure that
the bearing moves with the strut they
want to see that the bolt and the bolt
canister can move together that the
bearing and the strut move together
outboard on the non-radiator side of the
iea
okay
all right
safety together
okay I I see your safety tether so it's
clear I'm going to continue to sound
freak okay just be aware since I'm on
this side it goes a little bit and I've
seen it like a little above your head so
just keep an eye on it so that I see
that
great deconfliction guys you know my
goblet saying please copy koichi
gauntlets in place and as you translate
outboard also please don't translate on
the radiator base handrail
and creature
copy Duke you'll be looking for S4
handrail two two three one
foreign
we recommend fairleading at S4 handrail
842213 copy and that's after you cross
over to the radiator side and then once
you're on the radiator side you'll be
heading outward to the Q pin
okay
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
right
yeah and that's correct Gucci
more or less Nader
president
over to the radiator side yeah
okay copy that
foreign
[Applause]
so I want to take a minute to go over
some of the directional cues that you
might be hearing
two two one four
copy fair lead on two two one four
that's looking good we've got a great
view in your hiccups
great
so if you hear an s or a p we're going
to be talking a lot about the S today
whether it's the starboard side of the
space station it's paired with a number
S1 being very close to the center of the
space station S6 being as far out as you
can go we're also hearing the words like
in inboard and outboard inboard means
you're moving towards the center of the
space station and our ground Division
and Cardman has told them to go outboard
meaning more towards the outer edge of
the space station
two two three five
okay copy 2235 is exactly where you'll
be stowing that cable bag
reminder you'll want that handrail
toward the non-radiator side
okay
yeah I've got the knit set and
adjustable down to handrail two two
three one
it might be our T-Rex
copy and once you're done with that
we'll have you get in position near the
lower stretch
ah
[Applause]
Duke once you're happy with that mid
strap we'll have you head over to the
lower strut and actually get your eyes
on we'll take a wiggle and GAP check
from you we've got a couple seconds do a
hand over here
so we'd actually like you to just head
to the left side
um since we've got koichi stowing that
uh cable bag
yeah we're coming up on a sunset
okay cable that'd be sold at the uh
we're in a brief Handover period now the
space station and orbital daytime as it
flies over Ukraine nearing an orbital
night time so for this reason our ground
IV and spacewalking group here on the
ground and Mission Control that you're
seeing now have asked Nicole man to take
a look at the lower strut remember we're
talking about two different components
that they have left to install of this
structure they want to check out the
lower street that cable bag and totally
install the midstret so head out to the
left lower strut NASA astronaut Nicole
man has stowed the midstret and now
she's working on inspecting the lower
straw to get both of your eyes on and
get those wiggling Gap checks done as
soon as possible
copy Duke I like that plan we'll leave
the deconfliction up to you
okay
you've got a view of the the ladies in
charge of the room here um in the middle
of your screen in the black blazer and
the darker hair is Chloe Maring our
flight director today
and the woman just to her right is with
the blonde hair and the black blazer
that is NASA astronaut Xena Cardman and
you are hearing her voice communicating
the plans of our space walking team here
in Mission Control relayed to the crew
through Xena Cardman
foreign
we're back with our live views now NASA
astronaut Nicole man is going to get
started checking out the lower strut
that they're working on doing a couple
of tests while we're in an orbital
daytime
okay
except in 21 area
as well hopefully you have a good happy
here
that's perfect we'll be following along
in your heckers just a couple quick
cautions no sudden movements on the
masked canister and uh no big lateral
loads maximum load is 50 pounds avoid
cyclic loading and don't Import Parts
don't impart forces into the mod kit
until we've got those collar bolts
tightened
hold on that's a little more clean so I
can get better eyes on the bolts okay
I'm gonna have peel off
okay I see uh
about that
do you have a good heck of you uh Veena
I don't see a gap between the set
and then uh a spherical bearing
but
the vehicle being does not have any Gap
okay we copy a good Gap check
you have a good heck of you
wait okay taking a look now yeah give us
just a couple of moments to analyze
all right Gucci we are definitely happy
with that Gap check we'll have you also
perform a wiggle test
perfect and just a reminder we're
looking for uh if they move that the
bolt and bolt canister move together and
if they moved at the bearing and strut
move together
okay
so I don't see any movement from here I
didn't see that either let me push it
a little bit and then the both heads and
the uh the the canister don't care the
move together
and then
Flats in the circle bearing that move
together
I see that movement
s
we do see that that sounds like a good
check for us we're just verifying with
all of the interested parties
okay
so some good news here in Mission
Control our space Walkers performs both
a gap check and a wiggle check okay Gap
check making sure that the items that
they've installed lay flushed they're
not angled in any way misaligned they've
also done the wiggle test to confirm
that the bolt in the bolt canister and
the bearing in the strut move together
we had troubleshooting options that the
team has worked on this week in the
event that either the gap or the wiggle
check
one or the other didn't work but
according to our space Walkers both the
Gap and the wiggle tests are good the
strut is fully installed
copy Duke
percentage
no problem koichi
and Duke a firm you can get the midstret
and put it on your brt
so this is some good news the lower
strut is installed and installed
properly
however the work is not entirely done on
it in order to get to this bolt that
they had the questions on they had to
take off some multi-layer insulation and
now they're just going to work to put
that back on
this of course protects the hardware
From the Rough environment of space the
big picture update for you both for your
essay we are currently 30 minutes ahead
of the timeline so amazing work there
and our limiting consumables
with medox put us at a pet of about
7.25.
good news
from this battery looks like it's
covering
just that corner that your fingers on
now okay there you go yeah okay
great
and see now you're happy with the uh am
I right here on the lower shot at n21
we are indeed we're happy with that Moi
on M21 and we'll take a glove hap and
Gauntlet check from you
okay uh Bob is good yeah they're happy
today
guiji and check that your gauntlets are
down as well
and the first task of the day is now
complete already they the spacewalk
began at 6 45 a.m central time they
headed out to their work site on the 1A
power Channel where they found this
support structure they had built it
during their previous Eva earlier this
month but they still had a couple of
items left on their to-do list including
checking out one of the bolts on this
lower strut they did two tests on it a
gap check and I wiggle check and right
on the first try both of them were
successful so now they're moving on to
their next task which is completely
installing the mid strut
so if you'll remember they had already
begun work on the lower strut and they
just needed to do one more evaluation
but they do need to completely install
the mid strut that's what they're
working on now
perfect Duke you can head to the apfr
you'll extend the Ingress Aid and
Ingress Ava
so you just heard Xena Cardman let our
spacewalker here in the red suit
excuse me the suit with the red stripes
and a Coleman's Ingress the apfr good
news ev2 you can head to the cable bag
and you'll grab the TBA bag from that
cable bag stow it on your mini
workstation
and then translate to the left side pad
install so what exactly is this apfr
well it stands for articulating portable
foot restraint it's essentially a
foothold that can be installed at a
workstation you can imagine that working
in microgravity can be difficult not to
float around while you're working with
your tools and the foot restraint holds
keep the spacewalker in place it really
frees up their hands as well
remind me to grab it off before I hand
it to kariki sometimes a foot restraint
is installed to the end of the robotic
arm and the astronaut can be driven
around to different work sites sometimes
carrying bulky items the robotic arm
won't be used in today's spacewalk but
they'll use foot restraints in this area
that were already set up for them at
their work site earlier this month
interesting
copy Duke
should I forgot the GoPro
um if you if you want to put on the
Handler right
now
okay I'll put it in there we are now one
hour into our spacewalk today
we are now in an orbital night time here
aboard the International Space Station
you see that glowing line there that's
actually the Earth
and what are spacewalkers up to well our
ev1 NASA astronaut Nicole Mann is
getting into her apfr or portable foot
restraint kind of holds her in place at
her workstation so she can begin
installation on the mid strut meanwhile
NASA excuse me Japanese astronaut
kuichiwakata is stowing the cable bag
that he brought out earlier
next to the cable bed and then locked
don't be Gucci
um can you confirm that it's your first
settings I think we have adjusted them
before we had left so um I think I need
a roll of hotels
checking Duke
Duke that's a roll of hotels
yaw 12.
okay that's a rule of hotel and a yacht
club
that's a quick Handover in about 10
seconds
we're in a brief Handover period as we
work to regain
communication with our satellites both
video and audio
for now you have live views of Mission
Control Houston where teams are
supporting the a spacewalk outside of
the International Space Station with
NASA astronaut Nicole Mann and Japanese
astronaut kuichiwakata they're finishing
up work that they started on during a
previous Eva back in January
they're installing a modification kit or
a support structure that will one day
house a roll out solar array
they've already completed their first
task of the day and are slightly ahead
of schedule
did affect that area
okay copy and you've got the GoPro set
up on 2230.
yes
copy that's great okay on your way out
to the side pad location reminder it's a
fairlead on S5 handrail 2108
that's a long horizontal handrail
just below the mass canister basically
two handrails further outward from 2230.
this 1A power Channel mod kit for my
toes
this mod kit launched on Northrop
grumman's 18th Commercial resupply
Services Mission and cygnus delivered
them back in November
[Applause]
stay here
okay dude
okay uh all right I'm walking okay let
me just get up there okay
oh
my God
okay so uh
yeah that's
yeah uh you're almost yeah you're Loop
down left side is good night's coming
off
a little more forward
while our spacewalkers are getting ready
to start work installing the mid-strut
portion the last piece of the puzzle for
this support structure that they're
building today in this part two of a
spacewalk if you have any questions
about today's operation be sure to
submit them using ask NASA and we'll try
to answer them on air yes
now you're in and looks like uh
you go there
Nicole Mann is now in position
successfully inside of her portable foot
restraints at the work site
kuichiwakata is configuring his tethers
and equipment that he brought out making
sure it's out of the way but still
Within Reach and then he'll Begin work
on it as well
okay
that's always Fair
difference is
further
okay then let me go behind the epfr
all right
okay
Jeff till in push it in this view that
we're looking at now is what they're
working on this is the mod kit or
support structure that will one day
house
irises or ISS roll out solar arrays go
in further
foreign
the round part that you're seeing there
is the Mast canister and that's what
they need to install the mid strut to
almost push it down
okay now lift your uh
oh now you're in okay
ah
go ahead okay okay all right
during part one of this spacewalk one of
the plates that's at the end of the Mast
excuse me that's at the end of the mid
shred didn't quite sit flush against the
mass canister there were some components
in the way perhaps some insulation so
the ground team has worked all week on
some troubleshooting measures and
koichiwakata and Nicole man are working
on those now
complete
foreign
uh
the white covering that you see on these
struts that's the mli the multi-layer
insulation they're working to peel that
back so they have a good view of the
work site
I saw great work
okay
we'll also have you remove the Locking
tip pin from the mid strut
okay that's the pedia bag and the uh
commit the position of the white glass
of the
handrail the vertical handrail
that'd be Gucci that's a great spot for
that TVA bag
we can get to work on that side pad
interface you'll clear the mli from the
GSE fixtures
on the left and right side
and Duke for that pip pin once you've
got that removed check that the washer
is behind the detents
okay the washer is behind the defense
perfect you can extend the mid strut and
once quiche is in place you'll work with
him
you just heard NASA astronaut and Xena
Cardman give Nicole man the okay to
extend the mat also the mid stripes
yeah we'll have kuichi working on the
mli Duke you can help him by reporting
when the mli is clear of the side pad
side slots
please
so this mid strut is telescopic meaning
it can be extended out like a telescope
so it does have some tolerance during
installation mid strut reminder you can
also lock out your rep with slack in
order to avoid any additional side loads
and I think uh
it's kind of difficult to fail these
down along the unrail that I think right
now it's not very in the way for uh Duke
so I'm going to continue with this
safety data config
I'll uh
remind me when I had John Cena I'm gonna
have to move his Safety Center
copy you both
kuichi will be watching in your heck of
you and just give us words once you've
got the right side and the left side GSC
pad clear of the mli and the velcro
re-engaged
okay
copy that
I'm gonna start with the right side
following the text of the video that you
together
we'll all be uh humming a song
oh yeah
actually was the feeling I see this
analyze some
because of the
interference
so to recap where we're at now
our space Walkers kuishi wakata and
Nicole Mann are starting to install the
mid strut the last piece that they need
to install to complete the support
structure needed for a future solar
array right now they're working on
peeling back the layers of multi-layer
insulation so that they have a good view
of the work site
great work we'll have you work on the
left side as well and just a reminder
about that uh obviously
yeah
website has enough
is uh at first the distance from the
receptacle bracket but the as you
mentioned that they need to have some
slack at the top of this area so I'm
going to relocate a little bit
and yeah as long as that mli just fully
clear of the slot we're happy
wakada has successfully removed the
multi-layer insulation on the right side
and is working on the left side
okay it looks like uh
first experience I think they're happy
about plans
to the bracket
do you think Duke
all right with that then I will uh
you agree Dina
I do agree we are ready for that side
pad right
great
and once you receive it from duke
duke has her rent locked out we'll take
some inspections of the tape side tape
on the side detents
reminder
and I'm going to put those uh plungers
once again
until I installed it
now with that multi-layer insulation out
of the way
with the multi-layer insulation now out
of the way they're going to move on to
the troubleshooting measures they had
attempted to install this mid strut
during their previous spacewalk but ran
into some issues getting it flush up
against that mass canister so now
they're going to try some of the fixes
that the ground came up with
yeah I can yeah but we can leave it now
right
that's right right
okay
all right
and yeah just make sure you have enough
slack in that rep before you locked it
out
yeah
Perfect all right here we go
they're getting ready to install the
first side that's the far side or the
topmost part of your screen to the mass
canister
the mass canister is that big
cylindrical bit that you see on your
screen there
koichi would koichiwakata is taking lead
on the install of this side of the Mast
of the mass canister
and hey koichi from our view it looks
like maybe it is pitched toward you a
little bit so that the bottom detent is
engaged with the top detent is not quite
engaged
we can also install that adjustable
and just give it a little
um
okay yeah it looks like it's coming off
now all right
okay you recommend that using digestible
on this side I do yes
okay I'll try that
they're in the process of installing one
side of the mid strut to the Mast
canister it's laying flush and is good
and now they're working on soft docking
it which appears to be successful so in
a soft dock you get everything lined up
and flush before they're able to hard
knock or drive the bolts into it your
brt on that vertical handrail there and
that way you can get two hands on the
side pad if you need let's see
let's see I already have the Yorkie
and it's
uh yeah I've been using that
[Applause]
it's already tightening but still it
does
give me a
favor enough condition but don't try
okay
to the long hand rail and I'm cinching
it down
copy and you'll need the right side to
be engaged as you're cinching the left
side
that again okay oh
okay
it looks like it's
special engaged
and it's already fully fixed
okay copy the right side is engaged and
that adjustable is cinched looks like
the right side is not engaged if it's
coming off that far
and from The View that I have it does
still look like
the top detent
is not engaging
you've got a view now of the Mast
canister and in the middle of the screen
that pole that you see there is the mid
strut that they're trying to install
see the plate at the very end of the mid
strut a little bit that's what they're
trying to lay flush up against
this side is free and uh
yeah okay that's great and then uh
it's good it's good okay it's good
they're doing a number of
troubleshooting measures now here in
Mission Control relaying them to the
crew one is to move around the
multi-layer insulation which you just
saw the Pair of Hands doing there
okay copy koichi
[Music]
ah
okay
grab the adjustable down still
first of all it's here
once again okay I was just wondering if
it would help if I actually let go so
that there were no uh
from this end let go I just thought
we've not attached yet the adjustable is
on the handrail but not on the side pad
yet right
there Luigi once you do reattach it we
recommend putting that adjustable with
both hooks to the tether loop on the
side pad otherwise you won't get enough
slack out of that adjustable in order to
really cinch it tight
I'll do that
okay perfect
right side is engaged looks like
copy
and we're doing really well on time so
if you want to take any moments to
readjust your brt or anything I wonder
if you take your brt and come at that
handrail from the left side instead of
the right side it'll help you get in a
better position
that effect or from the right side uh
yeah see how your uh the jaws of your
brt are coming from the right to the
left to that handrail if you come from
the opposite direction it may get you in
a better position for the left side
defense
oh okay
yeah correct
but I'll leave it to your house on
expertise since you are actually there
okay okay
okay
180 hours that's not work so I'm Gonna
Change 90 degree valve
copy Gucci
all right
I will relocate the adjustable with my
Yes red
following the part one of the spacewalk
on January 20th ground teams here in
Mission Control were able to come up
with a number of troubleshooting items
for this mid-strut this includes using
tethers or various tools at their
disposal to help get this mid strut
installed they've got a checklist of
things that they can move down trying
one after the other if necessary until
the soft dock is complete and pulling on
it in order to get kind of an up and
down wiggle motion on the left side
while keeping tension on the right side
without taking it around the handrail
yeah
right that's what I'm doing now and then
like it doesn't go in
copy
well it looks like it's the right side
seems to be
actually engaged or completing days but
the left side doesn't go in
finder doesn't go in
okay Gucci
what have you take the adjustable the
other end of that hook
bring it back to the side Pad cover Loop
okay get it cinched so that the right
side stays engaged and then we'll try
the hammer It's Hammer Time
I'll do that
okay yeah that's the adjustable
moving on to the next tool at their
disposal some of the troubleshooting
items here they used a adjustable
equipment tether on the handrails try to
get that into place now we're moving on
to using one of the Hammers that they
have in their toolbox
okay I will use the hammer then
let's go duke
all right let me know if I if I need to
position this better but it looks like
it's pretty solid yeah right yeah it
looks like it's the right side is
engaged
reaching for his hammer now
yeah that's good words for me both and
it's really looking like that top detent
is just not going in so I think that's a
good place to start koichi once you've
got that hammer okay and you're Tethered
to the Hammer just a reminder we'll
start with some gentle taps
the maximum load on the BGA is 50 pounds
and wait 30 seconds between attempts
copy
as you hammer
okay so I'm not gonna release the Reds
from the hammer just to keep it in the
media bag
sounds good to me
they've been uh
every 30 seconds
that's about 50 pounds
hey uh flight one
like
no change
about 30 seconds and just a reminder to
hammer kind of right where the tip of
that arrow is you're aiming for that
upper detent
okay copy that
pass
you're seeing the point of view of
Japanese astronaut koichiwakata on a
spacewalk to install a support structure
to hold solar arrays one day again he's
working on the mid strut it's the thing
you see on your upper right most corner
of your screen that's the insulin
insulation there as well sometimes
underneath his hammer you'll see
something with an arrow that is what
he's trying to soft dock with the mass
canister you can see he's tried a number
of troubleshooting items there's a
tether in place there kind of pulling it
into place and now he's using his hammer
to try to get into place as well okay
correct it it went in a little bit
the goal here is for the mid strut to
lay flush and soft dock so that the
bolts can be driven and it can stay
locked into place
did not go in
should I hit the Lower Side again or
should I hit the upper side of the arrow
sounds like we're making some good
progress we might try alternating
between the two see if you can get any
more progress on the upper
okay puppy in work
wakata is relaying what he's seeing down
to the crew here in Mission Control
Eva teams and Mission Control are
Consulting on what to do next and how
best to soft dock the piece of equipment
that he's working to get into place
again
after that doesn't go in it seems to me
that they need to use the uh fires
okay copy koichi will have you try the
pliers
okay puppy and yeah big picture we want
as you're looking at the side pad a
little bit of gentle rolling motion as
you're trying to wiggle it on just see
if you can kind of walk those detents in
place
and so if needed we can have Duke from
her end do a pitch so body up and down
from her end as you're trying to work
the detention place
okay yeah that will be helpful uh
I would say
so make this uh
bite that
goes this way you know what I mean
so from that would be a yeah from my
perspective
uh so your body is better
y'all
no that's not the orientation uh
uh the rod in this orientation okay yeah
that's it yeah that's the
koichiwakana trying a number of items to
get this mid strut installed and soft
dock to the mass canister
he's used some tethers to help help kind
of pull it into place he's used his
hammer to also try to to get it flush
there as well which made some progress
but now he's going to move on to using
some pliers that he has out there at his
disposal you can see them on your screen
now
do you see the gap
on my right side here
it's in Shadow right now I'm opening up
I do see it yes okay I'm pointing
fire and
because of this gap on this side the
left side doesn't have any gaps so it's
really tight on the left side where I'm
pointing at now
it seems to me that somehow the right
side needs to engage further to the left
because there's some gaps here
I see what you mean okay
checking koichi
it seems to me that we may need to use a
hammer to hit on this right side so that
this side pad will shift to my left
copy koichi let's think on that for just
a second is it
vertically oriented uh in the middle
of that GSE pad
like is it able to slide down at all
maybe it's interfering with
the top of the slot where the tongue is
supposed to fit in
foreign
copy
so if it doesn't slide up and down
anymore
yeah it looks like it
okay copy we like your idea of using the
hammer to gently tap on that upper right
corner
of the side pad
this area
that I'm pointing up with my right hand
right index finger
yeah can we see what you're pointing at
is where you will want to tap gently
with the hammer
okay
and Duke we can have you let go of your
end as well to alleviate any side loads
that may be imparted
koichi while you're tapping with the
hammer
you'll try to push in on the left side
as well
you can see that silver box there at the
center of your screen that's a piece of
equipment that they're trying to lay
flush against the mass canister he is
tightened down as you can you could use
your mini workstation end effector maybe
if that helps you but you'll need
something to react against so that you
can be pushing on the left side
and then
the stationary Factory detached so I
will try that again
okay I will
tap again in this direction
copy koichi yeah and it may be just ever
so slightly too high vertically on the
GSE pad so as you're pushing in also try
to push a little bit down
and we've got a Handover coming up in
about 15 seconds
okay
[Music]
so we've got live views here of Mission
Control you can see towards the left
side of the aisle the gentleman standing
in the vest that's Keith Johnson he's
our lead spacewalk officer for this
operation he's Consulting with that team
of experts there on what they're saying
on the equipment while also hearing what
kuichi is relaying that he can see
through his eyes and trying to determine
the best step forward
you can see this group in a bit of a
huddle now
push the defense down with the fire and
the
kuichiwakata is relaying what he's
trying and what he's seeing to this team
here and they're giving recommendations
on on the next moves
yeah I hit the uh on the right side but
also it does not move at all
so let me
so I do
apply it too again
by itself
we're back with live views now at the
International Space Station
okay we've got your heck of you back
koichi
and I know it's going to be tricky
needing to use your left hand to react
the forces but as you're pushing that
detent you also need to push in on the
side pad so that it's going into the GSC
pad on the mass canister
okay
hey
you know what you mean and I have brt
and then I mean it works listed in
effect there
it's really difficult because that's the
fourth of pushing this in in this
direction
yeah definitely understand you need a
third hand basically
you're hammering from the right side did
not work and then you did this
is the
it is first so
preventing this
coming in
I'm gonna try to depend on the bottom
side as well
every person that
Erp
foreign
the right side is probably engaged in
appropriate position
standby
okay
all right koichi we are talking it down
here if we could get your best big
picture summary of what you think is
going on what might be interfering
whether it's the side pad itself if it's
the detents
and I think you got that bottom detent
engaged before
is that correct
all right
no it's not very positive I don't think
it was
engaged there seems to me that the
defense is not the interference
just the uh the width of the uh
the width of business iPad
it may not be
to give us
do you think the lip of this iPad is
actually hitting the GSE
side pad structure
[Applause]
okay that's also a negative I think it's
uh
no uh
this left side the lip is already
engaged on the right on the left side of
this uh structure so
um
[Applause]
it's like from here but the distance
even if I push it down it does not
but if I push down the detect Phil it
does not engage
is it possible to type in N1 and M4
checking guichi that may uh I may give
more room for in one of them sleep
engaged
but this time can I engage in one of
them three with the impact
s to
yeah Gucci we do not recommend that will
not start engaging any bullets until we
have those detents in place
copy that
copy that so uh
any other
accidents that I can take
kawichiwakata reporting what he can see
what he has tried as well as given his
own recommendations to the crew here in
Mission Control they're weighing their
options and talking as a group and
sending some recommendations up
up his way
can I uh Nina can I release it and see
what kind of interference especially I
can see maybe I can answer some of the
questions that you have yeah we like
that idea kuichi let's have you do that
and we'll be talking some solutions here
on the ground
okay copy that
I'm gonna uh both of the adjustable and
then
you got to fight that
kind of different it has
it has another season one adjustable
from there
you didn't mean to hold on to it uh it's
okay you can you have likely
The View you're getting now is the
spacesuit with the red stripes is now
it's astronaut Nicole Mann she's holding
the other end of the midstret while
kuichi's working on that that gray
Square working it to get flush against
the mass canister it just goes in
God uh scratch this
by the defense float too so hit them
obviously the theory
so it seems to me that began uh
releasing the defense approaching the
distance is the way to go
and then looking at on the side side
I don't see any interference on this
side
so thank you it is the
weekend
and then
I guess uh
I need to stabilize my body position and
then apply
a stable
support for the plunger
and then say that that you have
different
uh
can you send it now the mixture yeah
give me a second okay
all right
[Applause]
but the left side doesn't go in
now because of the detent
foreign
to astronauts are out on a spacewalk to
complete installation of a mod kit or
mounting bracket for future solar arrays
they completed they started work on this
back on January 20th and they're back
out for their second spacewalk to
complete their work
um the first time around this mid-strut
that they're working on now gave them a
little bit of trouble so now they're
back for a part two to try to get that
into place teams here in Mission Control
are looking at the hardware now they
have an exact model of the hardware
taking what kuichiwakata is saying and
seeing and feeling with his hands to try
to come up with a solution
he has a number of tools at his disposal
that he may be able to use he may also
be able to elicit the help of NASA
astronaut Nicole Mann who's holding on
to the other side it is a pretty tight
work space so Mission Control teams are
still determining the next steps
because uh I think I I need the the free
hands to do that yeah so uh being a do
you agree it's the dude comes in here
and you know on the lower side on the
long handrail and then she she can
either work on the fires while I push in
yeah checking on that koichi
okay before we have Duke come over we do
like the suggestion to have Duke do a
yawing motion from her perspective
as koichi is ideally depressing both of
those detents with both pliers
I think a steady gentle pressure from
you
if you can get the yawing motion
heading to your body left eventually the
strut will hit a pin on the side pad and
that way you'll be able to actually
apply pressure as opposed to before you
hit that pin it'll be rotating around
out there
indeed it's difficult to
use to
the thing that
yeah we could have you I will try
depress both with your fingers and try
to get them depressed as much as
possible and then see if we can get it
installed before the defense pop back
out
and stretching the tape okay
okay
like that
we're in a split screen view now both
spacewalkers working together so you can
visualize this mid strut as this long
telescoping pole so it can extend or
retract as needed NASA astronaut Nicole
Mann is holding one end of this pole
while koichiwakata is holding the other
his view on the right side there wakada
trying to get that piece that he's
holding in his hands flush up against
with that rectangle out on the masked
canister
Nicole man is now going to work with him
kind of twisting and wiggling from her
end to try to snap it into place as well
meanwhile here in Mission Control we've
got models of the exact equipment that
they're using here in Mission Control
being looked at for possible solutions
as well checking hang on
okay
but the other one is not the thing that
they just done enough
copy
which one is staying and which one is
not
ified and
if you flip it's going to be your
opposite I precise will stay and the
Lower Side the tank is almost damaged so
it doesn't stay okay copy kuichi thanks
stand by we're talking plans here
okay
we're now about two hours into this
spacewalk estimated to last about seven
hours
they've already completed their first
task of the day of doing some
inspections on the uh on the lower strut
and now they're working on installation
of the mid strap to get those detents
more depressed
do you think you're able to hold one end
of the tape
so the non-loop end right
kind of keep some pressure on it with
your thumb
and then peel up the other end slightly
add a little more depression to that
detent
and then reinstall the tape with a
little bit more tension
okay I think it's possible under the
paper breaks up
can I you ever go to do that
hey firm kuichi
okay in work
and you may want to pinch the other end
with your some uh
coming at it from a slightly different
direction oh we see the tape broken
yeah you can get that in your uh trash
bags
yes I can
oh you don't want to use this date
anymore
correct checking koichi
[Music]
if you think there might still be enough
sticky on that length of tape that you
pulled off
in order to reapply with a little more
tension over that detent
you can give that a try
that
[Music]
astronaut koichi wakata working with
tape in an effort to get that piece in
his hands flush with the rectangle on
the mass canister there she's trying to
soft dock them and tape is just one of
the many tools he's using to get that
into place
foreign
ly a bit of the tape has come off but he
has an additional roll of tape there in
his tool bag if needed but if he thinks
he can use the existing piece Mission
Control has relayed and that's okay too
[Music]
easy one PCV
foreign
[Music]
while this installation is giving
koichiwakata a little bit of trouble
tmcr and Mission Control just relayed
that even though we're at the two hour
mark there's still plenty of time left
in this spacewalk to troubleshoot and
plenty of ideas still left to try
they remain optimistic about this
installation
can you see on the left side the holes
that the details go into
let's take it can you see on the left
side the um
familiar with the defense would go into
yeah there's a yeah it's
it's here at the on the side that
is appearing and so there's some
scratches whether you can go yeah I mean
the defense are not sliding and it's
making that dents here
so uh I think
to be the best option is to have you
come here and then
uh manipulate this uh
uh fire
and I push the right tab
okay so it sounds like the defense are
moving okay
pushing far enough right
and the tape
they're not keeping them plungers in
place yeah
I cannot think uh any better options
than that now
we're following along guys and talking
it on the ground here standby
okay
foreign
Mission Control are troubleshooting this
mid-strut debating on bringing Nicole
Mann over to the work site
or perhaps suggesting koichiwakada use
some of the tools a plier or some
hammers to the tape at his disposal to
try a couple of things before she comes
over
foreign
okay guys we are talking a plan to have
Duke come over to you in the meantime
we'll have you do one more try with
koichi just in place there
well we'll have you do koichi is get in
a as good a body position as you can
you'll engage the right side of the side
pad so that that tongue is in the groove
you'll install the adjustable
on that handrail just to keep the side
pad in place as best you can
and then we're going to use the pliers
handle as kind of a pry bar and I'll be
talking you through that in just a
moment
okay
basically get it installed as best you
can you'll take that adjustable around
the handrail and back to the tether
point and then I'll have some more words
for you in a moment
okay copy that didn't work
foreign
we're talking one more thing here
what about you
yeah
okay Gucci we're going to have you grab
the pliers
okay and insert
into the tether point
toward the mass canister yeah exactly
yeah so gently go through the hole of
the tether Point okay kind of aiming
between okay yeah not too far you want
the bottom end of the pliers to just be
touching the metal of the side pad
and now you're going to yarn to your
left
okay bringing the pliers toward the
handrail that your left hand is on and
use it as a pry bar you may want to take
the pliers and go 90 degrees off from
where you are rotate them ready yeah
exactly so that you're not using the
bent portion of the pliers have a
straight face going there okay and apply
a gentle steady
pressure
and I'm seeing a much bigger Gap than
before up top so I think that detent is
not even starting to engage on the top
side
I think it is it's a
it's where it starts to engage
oh this
is but now the
uh
fire broke
give it
if it's not a lot of force but they're
just a tiny bit of us
[Music]
don't touch that of the pliers
okay okay and you can put them in your
trash bag Gucci
okay uh
Xena Cartman on your screen she's the
voice that you hear communicating with
the crew
that's bags disagree
copy we agree standby
kuichiwakata just attempted to use his
pliers kind of repurposing it as a as a
way to
plow the other side of it back into
place unfortunately the force was a
little too much for the pliers and they
snapped so koichi fortunately has a
trash bag up there with him and the crew
is just making sure that he doesn't
touch any of the sharp edges as we don't
want to cause any damage to the
spacesuits and now we're working on
another solution
one more just a moment
[Applause]
thank you
we're talking a plan down here guys
thanks for your patience
great
one more
all right
so we have one more one more
fire left yeah
what's that did you see any progress
when you did that or not no no no
progress at all
moving on now to the next
troubleshooting option having NASA
astronaut Nicole Mann move over one more
try before we have Duke come over to
where koichi is
will have her do that yawing motion so
going to her body left with her end of
the strut
and then koichi on your end
if you can get in as good a body
position as possible
stay stable
and use the pliers
you'll need both the needle nose pliers
and
the taped pliers
and we want you to be depressing both of
those detents at the same time while
Duke is doing her yaw in motion
okay
I'm saying that for ev1 PCD is at once
tcv at one copy
the needle notes are below your right uh
right below your PTC that doesn't taste
okay rather underneath your videos
okay
looks like NASA astronaut Nicole man is
going to stay put as they try one more
thing she's holding the other end of
this mid strut if you look towards the
top of your screen you can see that one
of her feet is inside of her portable
foot restraint so if she were to come
over to koichi she would need to egress
that and then Mission Control has the
path forward that they would like her to
take only if we reach that step
but you know you met uh I used the
needle nose in place of the one of the
fires right exactly
uh VRT and I may work system and
Defector locks
copy kuichi
it's a blood operation on one side I can
see one side clearly but the uh
that doesn't allow me to look at the
bottom side but the think I can feel the
plunger with the needle nose
okay copy if you're getting some good
tactile feedback as best you can
that's the right move
it
Falls
let me know and I can yaw some more
okay just a moment
Duke for you if we could have you hold
the bolt canister rather than the bolt
thank you
so I can only uh
I can feel the defense on the upper side
but
such a CD depends on the left okay and
I'm and I'm young left
okay and let me uh
first let me handle the broken pliers
that I don't
particularly use that one
Tina uh what's the uh plans with the uh
the damaged Flyers
should I just leave it outside it's
still tight it's connected so it doesn't
go anywhere but copy yeah we're
concerned about a sharp edge there so we
just want it to be out of the way and be
careful not to grab that end of the
pliers but understand it won't fit in
your trash bag
right
I'm gonna put it in possibly and it says
that so I don't accidentally cut it
copy sounds like a good plan I'm gonna
grab the other plier okay good plan I
grab the other player okay
recap a little bit of what's going on uh
we're doing a lot of troubleshooting on
how to get that mid strut installed it's
part of this greater installation for
this mod kit or support structure that
they've started building back in January
20th to the outside of the space station
one of the Maneuvers that they had
attempted was to use his pliers kind of
like a crowbar sort of to just kind of
nudge that rectangle that he's working
on into place unfortunately it resulted
in some broken pliers
it's very critical that our spacewalker
kawichiwakata does not touch any kind of
sharp edge so he has been working with
mission control on how to properly Stow
that away into safety
yeah
okay understand koichi I think that's
okay no problem if you don't have both
eyes on but if you feel that the Pliers
are in the right spot
then I think we're good to give this a
try
Duke for you will have you continue that
slow steady yawing motion
you may also do a gentle jostle in the
pitch direction as you're continuing to
apply a steady yaw pressure
probably
know when you're ready okay I'm ready
you heard our ground IVs in a card man
talking to Duke it's the call sign for
Nicole Mann our ev1 today
foreign
[Laughter]
[Music]
and with a round of applause here and
Mission Control and the teamwork of
Nicole man and koichiwakata they finally
got the piece they've been working on to
lay flush and soft docked
okay
can I use the uh
on your rent
stop it
I think those M1 and three
stand my kuichi
so you can think of this mid strut that
they're working on it's a bit of a pole
shaped item Nicole man on one side and
koichiwakata on the other and you are
going to start with M1 and M3 you'll
want to be very gentle as you do this
minimizing any side loads because it is
liable to pop off again
you'll be driving M1 and M3
approximately two turns being extra
cautious for cross threading
copy that
starting with M1 two terms
copy cuichi
the solution that seemed to do the trick
as I was explaining this is a
cylindrical shaped item with an
astronaut on either side of it you're
seeing the view of kuichiwakata now
working with that silver box that he's
been trying to lay flush against the
mass canister Nicole man was on the
other side and with their teamwork she
was able to take her side and kind of
nudge it wiggle it into place from her
perspective while kuichi laid it flat
and that was a solution that seemed to
work
complete
M3
copy koichi
and hey Duke for you a heads up we're
getting ready for a night pass and I
know you have your tcv in one but if you
want to do some wiggling and get warm
that's fine by us
everybody
once he gets two-thirds on each side I'm
going to go to M48 is that correct
hey firm Duke
yes
complete this is great news two turns on
M1 and M3 we've got lots of happy people
down here
okay you'll be getting your PGT now
setting Alpha One clockwise one
koichiwakata successfully soft dock the
mechanism that he's been working on that
mid strut the thing that you see going
from the center of your screen all the
way out to the right side he's now
working to drive the bolts into place
ah
okay PGT Alpha One clockwise one set
copy Alpha One clockwise one
the device that you see in
koichiwakata's hand we're looking at his
point of view now the thing with the
number five on it that's the PGG PGT or
the pistol grip tool it's a battery
powered handheld tool kind of similar to
to a drill getting those bolts into
place you could see it in motion now
working on M4
copy and standby koichi
all right quickie and we'll have you go
back to M1 and M3
with two additional turns using the PGT
okay and I'm an M3 two additional terms
the numbers that koichiwakata and
xenocarben are communicating from space
in here on the ground are the torque and
speed settings of this pistol grip tool
that he's using in his hands now
Let's Dance complete on M1
three
two original sounds complete on M3
and we're coming up on a Handover in
five seconds
we're in a Handover period here you're
getting live views of Mission Control
Houston where teams just work to
troubleshoot some issues that they were
having installing the mid strut the last
piece of the support structure that
they've been building for two Evas now
[Applause]
drilling them all into place
even though we worked on a number of
troubleshooting Solutions here today we
are not terribly behind schedule
and we're back with our live views as we
approach the two hour 30 minute Mark of
our spacewalk
importance complete on M4
copy four turns on M4 and I may have
missed it in the Handover did you get
two additional on M1 and M3
that's complete Eminem two M1 and M3 two
additional guns complete copy okay we
have four turns on all four of those
bolts
okay
Duke for you you can get L8 to Upper
stretch the midstret to the upper Strat
L8
and you'll be setting your PGT to Bravo
One clockwise 2.
perfect you'll be driving m28 about six
and a half to nine turns looking for
black line flush
koichi for you you'll be driving M1 to
M4 to torque an additional three to
eight and a half turns or so
this is to torque so you're looking for
good green light
okay all right three two eight turns on
on all the footballs this is
PGT settings are alpha 2 clockwise two
Alpha two clockwise two
three two eight turns
these directions again being the speed
and torque settings of this pistol grip
tool as well as the direction clockwise
or counterclockwise in this case it will
be clockwise
happy
and then one I got a green light and
talk about
2.8 pounds and uh it's a two and a half
pounds
copy two and a half turns additional on
M1
and two foot pounds correction 2.8
foot-pounds on M1 standby
foreign
standby
okay we're good to have you continue
with M2 M3 and M4
okay any order
a firm
okay love you thank you
M3 you got a green light it talks about
3.7 turns 3.7 foot pounds three turns
copy three turns and 3.7 foot pounds on
M3
on empty I got a green light broke down
3.7 pounds and then two and a
three-quarter turns
probably two and three quarters turns
three point seven foot pounds on M2
we're checking on that Bolt
okay
11.9 on the torque copy nine turns 11.9
and green light for you duke
that's a good bolt squeechy you can
continue as well
okay copy that working on M4
Duke can you verify also that you've got
black line flush
hey
great news okay you can install the
ministry
of 3.6
I found three turns copy 3.6 torque and
three foot pounds
Luigi you can store your PGT as well
and it's so far so good on the
installation of this mid strut where it
continues tightening the bolts on it
is
copy Dukes okay they're good now
everybody
is installed firmly on L1
perfect programming fit in itself
copy that Duke koichi you can release
ev1's rep from the midst right hand rail
once your PGT is stowed
copy that
first after that
unlock the red
yeah that's a good plan
okay I'm not
okay can I give it to you now yes sir
I'm ready for it all right
oh sorry maybe it was locked again
but it's like
okay see now what's that for me
next for you koichi you can release the
adjustable from the side pad tether
point and stow it on your mini
workstation and then we'll be doing the
mli install
once you're good we'll take a glove half
and Gauntlet check from you
so if you remember earlier during our
space walk our space Walkers had worked
to remove some of the mli the
multi-layer insulation it's that white
covering that you see there and now
koichiwakata is working to install a
back over the side pad
meanwhile here on the ground they've
asked our space walker Nicole Mann to
perform a happy Gauntlet check
being
the pads that they wear in their helmets
to avoid excess moisture she's going to
make sure that that's good and dry as
well as take a look at her gloves check
it out make sure that there's no notable
damage
okay everyone private good cop is dry
some of us are down
copy all Duke
and Tina adjustable is removed from the
side pad installed on my immediate
workstation
will take a glove happen Gauntlet from
you as well
okay Club is
it happens dry and conflicts are in
place
okay copy all because I'm looking at
this left bundle I don't see where you
added
I don't see where you if you add a Wi-Fi
I see the Wi-Fi that's sitting here
the Wi-Fi that's part of the integral
for the
reinstalled on the bundle you add an
additional one I believe I added an
additional one
do you have a record that Vina
I had a bit additional one that's
just checking
the previous EPA
now that the midstret installation is
complete they're going to move on to
tightening the collar bolts at the
midpoint of the mid strut they're driven
to rigidize the hole structure and when
the collar bolts are driven they clamp
down on this locking feature
and that has to be done before no room
so I can put weight on them
all right koichi we weren't tracking any
wire tie removal but we see you in a
good config
okay
I'm just tightening it up because of the
tools that you need it for the fact that
and putting them back in the PDF copy
will you see that in your hacker I think
that's a great plan once you're done
with that we'll have you work on the mli
on your end
and then we'll be working on the collar
podcast
we're on an orbital night time here on
the international space stations where I
get kind of a dark look with the these
headlamps that they've got on there as
they continue their tasks to kind of
recap what's been done so far they began
their spacewalk at 6 45 a.m Central
that's cool whose point of view you're
seeing on the right and Nicole Mann call
sign Duke on the left side After exiting
the hatch they went over to their work
sites and began work on the lower strut
part of the support structure that could
one day hold on irosa rollout solar
array this structure is needed to be
built before
these solar arrays can be installed
they began work on it back in January
and are finishing up so they began their
work on the left strut
one of the components that they needed
to look at and then they completely
installed the mid strut they did a
couple of troubleshooting items to get
them into the proper configuration that
they needed tried a couple of things and
finally got success and now they're
tightening the collar bolts all around
the structure rigidizing the whole thing
so it can be load bearing essentially
can house a roll out solar array
copy three on your tcv
wow
because you know the tools in the TDA
bag
um I returned them in the DBA bags and
it's still attached to the long hand
rail
okay copy
sure that the
am around that Bolt
okay
it's uh over the vault
and secured with the integrated wire tie
happy Gucci that looks good to us
it's come about
foreign
that'll be the next steps exactly okay
we'll have you adjust your body position
to reach the mid-struck collar
and while you're brt to the mid strut
handrail remember to avoid any torsional
loads into the strut
and we'll have PGT settings when you're
ready
kawichiwakata now getting into the
position to work on those collar bolts
laughs
ah
okay ready for the PCP settings for m29
and m30 okay Gucci that's Bravo 7
clockwise two
level seven clockwise to set
happy Gucci you'll be driving m30 and
m29 those are the collar bolts to torque
expecting about four to six turns
okay
and the grounds just communicated up to
kuiji wakada what his pistol grip tool
settings should be the torque and speed
that he needs to drive these collar
bolts
you can get a good view of what we were
talking about here on your screen now if
you want to take a look kind of in the
middle of the screen you'll see this
gray cylindrical shape the one closest
to the view is NASA astronaut Nicole man
holding everything steady right in the
middle we have our astronaut
konichiwakada he's working in the middle
point of this mid strut that's where
these collar bolts are
he needs to derive these in order to
rigidize the whole structure so that one
day these this structure can hold solar
arrays
this mod kit that he's working on
launched with Northrop grumman's 18th
Commercial resupply Services Mission
delivered by the cygnus cargo spacecraft
back in November
and the irosis that will be attached to
this mounting bracket will launch in a
SpaceX cargo Dragon cargo spacecraft
during the company's 28th Commercial
resupply Services Mission this summer
we're gonna on 29 I got a green lighted
post about three and a half pounds 25.3
touchdown that'd be three and a half
turns 25.3 on m29
I'm gonna work on the temperature okay
stand by Gucci
okay Gucci yes you can continue with m30
yeah
10 30 got a green light and turn down
25.6 shutdowns one and a half turns
probably four and a half turns 25.6 on
m30 standby
okay koichi you can drive m29 to torque
about four to six turns until the MTL
pops over you'll be setting your PGT to
manual ratchet
okay so uh not your ratchet and uh two
Tops on the m29
a firm
just as a reminder since we have the
wobble socket try to keep the PGT as
inline as possible and minimize the
wobble function of the wobble socket
copy that
and Duke are you all set with the cable
routing there
got it uh I got squishies that's still
undone and I've got it uh routed to the
lower
right here perfect thank you
work continues on this mid strut as
kawichiwakata on your screen Now is
working towards the middle of the mid
strut tightening these collars to
rigidize the structure
the ground just asked Nicole man if
she's ready to move on to her next step
she's not quite done here over at the
mid strut she still has some work to do
helping kuichi out with the insulation
it needs to go back on before they're
ready to step away from it but after
this task she'll move on to Route some
cables
even though you think it would help if I
hold your foot
do you have any try that
I'll try yes
I think this is
typing
and then
let me reorient my body
with my feet towards you okay
we like that suggestion Gucci
okay
getting away my
is that okay yeah that's good
yeah okay
okay
I need to come down a little bit more
but uh
yeah uh yeah
that's good
okay all right that's okay okay so I'll
try that which you can also switch to
the two inch rigid
a if that helps
going through it
is
extender if you want to give that one
more try
all right
so I can grab a hold of that extender
okay okay
let me say that now
all right okay
okay
how many additional turns were you able
to get
I think it's about the
about it one time
roughly one additional turn on m29 Okay
you can go to m30
[Applause]
that clockwise
and this will still be in manual ratchet
clockwise
when you're hearing words like m29 m30
these are these refer to the bolts
exactly that koichiwakata is working on
tightening and the numbers have to do
with his tool settings on just exactly
how much he's tightening it correct
looking for two parts okay
okay
copy
pop up
keep up from m30 it's probably about the
half turn
okay two pops and about yeah
um and 30. you're awesome happy Gucci
you can set your PGT back to motor and
stow it
thank you duke for your help all right
because I appreciate it
foreign
[Music]
can't see that nice to see each other
but it's still on my left leg Yeah it
was in between your legs right now but
once you move out
and so
um
okay great perfect yeah that's what I
wanted thank you but your your logo
coming from your right race Center
it's now wrapped inside of your uh
you know so you just need to rotate to
your left
get your local out of that way okay just
a moment
so local in this one right yeah
but this is
where is it going through he's just uh
your
thing on with your PTC
all right you're talking about TGT okay
there you go
we're now about three hours into our
space walk today moving right down the
checklist right out of the gate they
moved to work on the lower strut of the
structure that they're building and
completely installed the mid strut after
a lot of troubleshooting back and forth
here in mission control and up outside
the International Space Station they
were able to successfully install that
and they moved on to rigidize the
structure or tighten the collar bolts in
the middle of the mid strut that they
just built so they're still at it there
you can see it on the right side of your
screen okay thank you
next up on their checklist that's what
they're working on now they're working
on the multi-layer insulation was peeled
back for installation and now they just
need to put it back this instantly this
installation helps protect it from the
vacuo space
or a brief Handover period now so we're
getting live views of Mission Control
Houston
oh okay okay a firm and install that pit
pin on the telescoping side of the strut
in a small square boss near the collar
okay
I don't see it
underneath the uh that other example I
just come from later and look up
later okay
it's on the other side
we came to over here we'll be back with
you in a couple seconds
we expect to get our live views back
shortly meanwhile our spacewalkers
continue working diligently on getting
the insulation back over the mid strut
that they had just installed
next up in their tasks Nicole Mann is
going to Rick it's going to Route some
cables she's going to send them on a
path making her way around the space
station not necessarily installing the
cables but kind of setting them up for
success for a future spacewalk around
here on the color Bowl
back with you after a Handover
and Gucci were you able to get that
pipin installed right here I got the MRI
now 15 to be sold and that we were
working on the MRI
and we're uh
perfect that sounds great you'll be
fully closing it around the telescoping
end of the strut
and then installing the short wire ties
around the mli
Ichi for you you'll translate to the
right mid strip
going outboard around the mass canister
from long handrail to Long handrail
okay copy that faster I cover the uh
blood Vault area
oh can you work on that yeah
I think I'm gonna get that both of those
wire ties which I'm allowed to translate
on the uh
be able to get to that MRI a little
better
hey from Duke
okay so I believe I'm gonna pop out and
go grab my first two
koichiwakata has been working on the
left mid strut collar work is complete
on that and now he's making his way over
to the right mid strut to do similar
work
uh
you better go outside of that triangle
behind you right I'm gonna go around
here are you going outside the triangle
I am going uh on the other side of the
VGA
last time
I think I have to go around
yeah
that'll take care of your safety center
once you
can right right then it should be good
yeah yeah I think that was clear right
we do have you going outboard around the
mass character
okay I'm going around
the thing that can you confirm that I
can egress the apfr
hey firm Duke
and there we have NASA astronaut Nicole
Mann in view nicely lit as we enter an
orbital daytime
you can see by looking at her feet that
she's ingressed or gotten off of her
portable foot restraint that was keeping
her in place as she assisted
koichiwakata when he was working on the
installation of the mid strut
she is now moving on to other tasks
she's making her way over to the cable
bag it was originally taken out of the
airlock and stowed temporarily until
they needed it and that time is now
so she's going to work on some cable
routing while kuichiwakata works on the
right side of the mid-struck collar he'd
already worked to tighten and rigidize
the left side
foreign
[Music]
I had a temporarily O2 used type message
and disappeared
copy checking Ouija
kuichi we're looking into it some more
we think it may have been just a
momentary Spike but we'll continue
looking at the data you're good to
continue
okay
I'll see that I'm on the the right side
color both
stand by Gucci will have you hold Right
Where You Are
okay hold on
ah
good dude I'll just say that's good but
now I'm coming around all right
I'm just holding on to
all right sorry yeah levels
we're with you guys we're analyzing some
edar data for you koichi we'll have you
just hang out there for a moment
please
Gucci can we get a glove inspection a
very thorough glove inspection just make
sure that there's no damage to your
glove
uh good looks good to me
okay copy koichi let's have you look in
between all of your fingers just a
really thorough inspection so kind of
spread the fingers apart and really get
in there
hey fingers
okay uh they look good
this uh it's like the RTV
deal uh on the index finger but that's
just the uh
the TV
don't see any damages
copy guichi
well Twitter unfortunately that safety
feather goes right through the
app I need to get to the mass canister
at uh
you can go over it right
ass
no because it's kind of coming up so I'm
going to look and see maybe I can come
outboard and then come around
and then you need to get through the uh
the site pad or did you guys although
I'll be able to translate so that might
be a better option right okay
and uh I'd like to hang out there until
I'm done with uh
levels
yeah guys we're still looking at some
suit data
tracking your call about the safety
tether Duke are you able to add a fair
lead
two two three five uh
uh I'm having to go out forward and see
if I can figure something out
happy Duke
we don't have video right now so we're
uh listening to your words we'll be back
with you in a moment
okay
we're in a brief loss of signal we've
temporarily lost our video capabilities
but we expect to have them back very
soon shortly before we lost video
koichiwakata was performing a glove
check looking really thoroughly between
his fingers to see if he could see any
damage
koichi for you we've been looking at the
data we're going to keep analyzing it
for now we're good to have you continue
with your tasks
and we'll be keeping an eye on the data
see if we find any additional spikes in
that O2 use rate
okay
is that right hey firm yep you'll be
opening the mli on the right mid strut
to reveal the collar bolts
and I'll have PGT settings for you when
you're ready
okay
and then Duke for you
let us know if we can help you with any
Fair leading suggestions for the
handrail or anything like that we'll
take your words on what path you wind up
taking I got one here on Earth
108 I think that's gonna work I'm just
going to try this right here
copy Duke
and pretty sure I know the answer but
just to verify that's koichi's safety
tether on 2108 Duke
different
okay Xena I'm ready for PGT setting for
color balls on the right extract
okay similar to before we'll be doing
Bravo 7 clockwise 2.
7 how many turns
this will be about four to six turns on
M25 and M26
. okay
no I think I'm getting myself at a bad
spot here's me and I'm gonna back out
and uh in a different way
a few minutes ago koichi wakada was
working
on the right mid strut collar part of
his task for the day where he noticed a
brief spike in his O2 data he relayed
this information to the ground and we
paused all activity as ground teams
investigated what the cause could be
he did a thorough glove check and his
levels had gone down right away
so during this pause and after some
evaluation our team decided that now
that we are back at normal levels and it
was a brief Spike and the glove check
was good we're gonna continue on but
teams are going to continue to monitor
the situation
stand by Duke
okay guys back with you after Andover
and Duke a firm you can translate in
order to do the safety tether routing
that you mentioned
well today um did I use that hand roll
on the midst truck a firm Duke to put on
the wire size or is it riding so wait
okay great thank you
okay yeah foreign
got a green light and talk about 25
points
zero if it bounce and then four and a
half pounds
copy four and a half turns 25.0 on the
torque
for M25 and M26
you'll be setting your PGT to manual
ratchet clockwise now
be
and your records
clockwise
perfect and now you'll be driving M25
and M26 until you get two MTL pops just
let us know any additional turns you get
copy
kuichiwakata now finishing up tightening
the collar on the right mid strut
you can see him at the very top of your
screen wall towards the bottom NASA
astronaut Nicole man is working on some
multi-layer insulation
foreign
ah
Duke we lost your hekka for a moment if
you can hit the power button and turn it
back on that would be helpful
okay no problem
okay I got a good green light for the
hecka
copy Duke it'll take us a minute to get
it back
we'll get on my first wife right here
copy
yes
we've momentarily lost heck of views
from Nicole Mann this is the point of
view cameras that you've been seeing in
our coverage from time to time she did a
simple power cycle to get those back on
and we're gonna see if the solution
worked shortly
hey can we just watch your feet on the
solar array there
will want to get you in a good body
position so that your feet aren't
close to contacting
okay
copy that
I'll get lower
if you have that one wire tie down just
look it on the second now
stop you duke
koichi for you body positioning Wise
It's helped to be basically on your back
right that's where I started and uh
didn't have enough
ability so yeah I definitely understand
you can also put your feet on the lower
strut if that helps you brace yourself
oh okay
okay good suggestion thank you
kawichiwakata there at the top of your
screen finishing up work as he drives
some bolts to tighten up everything on
the right mid strut collar
it's just one of the final steps needed
on the structure that they've been
building for the past two spacewalks
foreign
our point of view cameras are back from
Nicole Mann you can see her putting some
wire ties around some multi-layer
insulation this sort of blanket that
protects the hardware from the vacuum of
space
it's at three quarters of a turn perfect
three quarters of a turn two pops on the
upper collarbolt
[Applause]
welcome to Lower Side televos
replace
do you want me to wait for the uh
collarbone before I translate for the
table
copy Duke
you can translate on the mod kit at this
point
okay great
but I think I'll go get rid of this uh
Square scoop
[Applause]
ah
that was rubbed up on the lower columns
that'll be one of two pops on the lower
collar bolts and Duke Before you depart
that area
copy second pop koichi Duke will just
have you do a final check of the Moi
around those collar bolts making sure
that the mli is not and there's no Gap
around the collar bolts
okay if it's okay with you I'm going to
drop this Square scoop and then when I
come back to do the cable I can tighten
up the colorful envelope coffee we're
good with that
we copied two pops for you any
additional turns on that Bolt
it's a health term copy half a turn
all right koichi for you you can set
your PGT back to motor and stow it and
then close the mli around those collar
bolts M25 and M26
for both of you you can translate on the
mod kit now
and just make sure to minimize any loads
on the mod kit and don't translate
simultaneously so deconflict your
translations with each other
preaching
okay yeah
and another check on their to-do list is
complete at the three hour 30 minute
Mark of the spacewalk recap some of the
events that has happened today they've
been working on this mod kit that you
see here the cylindrical thing here is
our math Cam and then we've got this
pyramid type structure they built like
90 of it during their previous spacewalk
back in January but they wanted to take
one more look at the lower strut the
gray that you see on the bottom of your
screen and totally installed this mid
strut that you see and the yellow you
can see the collar
so what they did was troubleshooted the
lower strut installed the mid strut
after some troubleshooting with the team
here in mission control and tightens
that yellow piece the collar to rigidize
the whole structure to get it ready to
be load bearing or having a irosa or the
rollout solar array launching this
summer sitting on it so it can be
deployed
they've just wrapped up putting the
multi-layer insulation the sort of
protective blanket back over it and now
they're going to run them out get
started on their new tasks uh they've
been together these two spacewalkers for
most of the spacewalk and they're
getting ready to separate
correct yep
Nicole Mann is going to work on some
cable routing so this refers to
connecting the new rollout solar arrays
with the Legacy arrays of course she's
not going to actually install anything
we don't have our irosa solar arrays
there yet but it does save some time on
a future
spacewalk to have these cables already
there routed all they have to do is plug
them in
analyze the wrapped around the colorful
area
I still needs to be it's the top part of
the bottom part needs to come up and
around
okay and once I get over there to my
side I'm going to ask you the same
thing
Duke we see you okay how about now
no there's two drop in the back we see
like the um the integrated ones that are
coming up from the bottom is you can
pull them up like that
it's a project can go up yeah but the
one in your grab it with your record now
pull that towards your head
now does that make sense
I don't think it can go down
or up here
bottom flap still has a gap so if you
take the two integrated set of plates
okay and pull them apart from each other
how about now
I was covering it
well maybe I don't always see that you
can see in that how much it needs to
cover but there's still a big gap in the
back
Duke we can't see it in your heck of you
so we'll trust your words to uh work on
that
okay
now look at me you see where my hand is
yeah on the bottom flap this is that
don't have a part like this
is so crunched up right now
for that one yes and then
yeah but you need to pull this down
pulling these apart
the other one I cannot reach your right
side is touching it
is
that's the one you're touching
so that's where you're right I cannot
touch it I cannot grab it
away from you
if you can tell myself a little higher I
think you'll be able to okay now I see
it yeah okay so thank you don't need to
come to your right like spread them
apart
don't move why don't you laughing at me
okay
the one that was in your left hand needs
to go
patient outboard
which one
if you reach with your left hand someone
you freezing out this one
yeah left hand is this one yeah okay
okay this one okay
put it in your right hand oh right here
okay yeah there you go okay great yeah I
used to come down on the other side of
the console yeah okay
awesome thank you
some teamwork going on outside of the
International Space Station to get this
multi-layer insulation this protective
blanket around the structure that they
just built
[Applause]
so we know that after this multi-layer
insulation is reinstalled uh Nicole Mann
is going to make her way over to some
cable routing meanwhile koichi wakata is
gonna work on getting a new portable
foot restraint
there are a couple of these outside of
the International Space Station and the
one that they had been using has been
having some trouble with the pitch knob
uh Wi-Fi yeah go outward and up
you can kind of think of these portable
foot restraints kind of like a tripod
you have your pitch and you have your
yaw those are the different directions
that you're able to move and it's the
pitch that they were having trouble with
it's not totally unusable they can use
it again but they prefer to use one
that's a little more smooth for future
Evas so kuichiwakata is gonna go take
the sticky one and replace it with one
that works a little bit better now it
looks like
this side
the top side of that so the side that's
closest to your head now has kind of A
Wrinkle a fold in it
if you can straighten that out that may
help cover more of the metal
you'll pull up on the top flop okay
clean it all out all right
let me uh move it up
so I pull it away from the undo it pull
it away straighten it out
then I think you'll have a better better
rocket hitting it around
oh this is I put it out and then
more anymore so
get better now can you see my left hand
sweetie yeah I see it take the Flop and
bring it off like this
yeah
undo it so that you can you got to get
everything straightened out it's like a
jumbled mess
and yeah koichi for you since you can
translate on the mod kit now you can
also move up and try to get up and over
so that you're looking down
on the mli maybe you'll be able to get a
better view of what you're what you're
doing there
okay copy that I'll move it around
yeah sorry I'm not doing a better job
explaining all right
okay then I'm going to continue with the
cable routing
uh
you can see Nicole man at the bottom of
your screen working on routing cables
exciting it out yeah
just like here on Earth we want to have
nice and tidy cables so she's working to
get rid of any slack and use wire ties
to kind of keep everything together and
neat
Gucci for you your plus is close to the
solar array so just watch that body
position there
I understand that
ah
it's kind of contacting part of the
solar array so you'll want to move
further toward the mounting bracket
yeah I think
my high side I cannot get there
and then
it's not just the bottom flap that needs
to be flattened out
would be from underneath right and the
uh
somehow on the left side too in the
middle is kind of open but I think we
cannot avoid it right
um
single here on the ATF arm working on
this
copy Duke
which if it helps let's have you add the
long wire tie
around that mli and see if we can cinch
it shut with the wire time so that's the
long wire tie that would be used for the
fhrc tie backs
okay uh
outside that and then uh still opening
here
on this site
how much of the opening
it's about a six inch hole so that a lot
of flap is not doing its job
business
oh that was actually really good guys I
hope you can switch it together yes you
got it wonderful get it now closed yes
okay all right
when you let go it pops open a little
bit
how about now
I'll give you a second
yeah the other side I cannot see
you're close
so that side in the middle there's an
opening but the
so it's
cannot be completely covered
but I mean it comes out it opens up okay
let's take a look how can you actually
start routing the cables and then once
we have those cables routed we'll come
back
to the mli okay
copy that
this one looks closed up here for me I
come from the inside
I think this one is good
yeah now he's good now he's looking good
yeah we see that in your head as well
you can see koichiwakata at the top of
the screen now has cables in his hands
he was working on closing the
multi-layer insulation around this
structure he got it pretty good
um had a couple of issues just fully
closing this last piece he was working
on but he's going to come back to that
and for the moment help Nicole man with
the cable routing
ah
okay three twists on the uh
camera on the mid strap
and Gucci for your awareness your uh
hekka and the helmet assembly is loose
of course it's still held on with the
straps but just so you know it's going
to be a little bit wobbly
okay
exactly
so on the long hunt rail there's so uh
biotide so I need to use the
wires like on the cable right
I see that
you can see it didn't work now wrapping
these wire ties around this bundle of
cables keeping everything organized
okay
for the cable to the Midwest
copy Duke
and on the arena on the long shot do I
need to put it on the station or can I
just do three twists around the uh
the handrail is fun
Gabriel okay
okay we're a brief Handover period the
International Space Station has a number
of ways to communicate with the ground
primarily through the tracking and data
relay or teen dress satellites when the
Space Station's antennas lose sight of
one of them it creates a loss of signal
like we're in now but tdrs is a
constellation of satellites meaning
there are several of these communication
satellites in orbit and it doesn't take
long to connect with another one
we should have audio and video back
shortly and these outages are planned
and mean we know when they're gonna
happen on the opposite side to pick up
your TBA bag
okay after uh
Duke translate devil
translate to the opposite side happy
Gucci
and actually Before you depart koichi
we'll have you install that wire tie
around the mli
okay
indeed the long wire tie around the mli
and just make sure that we have all of
those gaps closed up
okay I'll switch to the vertical and
rail
copy Duke
okay I believe my next step is it'll get
uh am I going to get the other tables
Duke first we'll have you guys both
working together to do a hecka scan of
the final mod kit mli config and just
make sure that all of those gaps are
closed especially after quiche installs
a wire tie around his
okay
now
we're getting video back
standby one
okay Duke we do have your hacker back
we're ready for that scan
ah
we've got about 30 seconds of video
remaining until I hand over
okay and koichi will also get your eyes
on Duke's side
and
if it looks good to you we may have Duke
head out to uh one Bravo
okay
let me check that
again all right
not attached to anything I think I'll
put things with the attached right
you know
maybe the walking fits in on the right
side
a firm yeah all of those fit pins should
be installed you think it's the Locking
pin for the telescoping feature of the
mid strip
okay now you're coming in shopping
we've got about two minutes of ready
comes here guys
Nicole man noted that she found a spare
pit pin meanwhile here on Mission
Control they've noted that they all the
pit pins do indeed need to be installed
onto this mod kit that they've been
working on so we're trying to find a
place for it
let me work on that
group you can hear we've got about two
minutes of radicom
okay I got you back and I did not copy
your laugh
recruiting that's it then
a firm ready comes here
we've got a minute remaining a firm all
pit pins should be installed did you
think that was the Locking pit pin for
the telescoping feature of the midstret
all right that's what I think it is on
the right side
okay guys in order to reinstall the pit
pin we'll need to open the mli again
koichi you can pause on the wire tie for
now
I missed that call
ready come hand over here
as we work to get our communication back
and our live views here shortly a little
update on what tasks have been done or
what are still to come
no Nicole man successfully routed cables
at the 1A power Channel That's where
they've been working okay guys this
whole time hopefully com should be a
little less Rowdy Dina Cartman's about
to give an update koichi will have you
pause with the wire tie Ops for now
and Duke you'll head to one Bravo
oh is that right okay
okay
perfect we'll also take a glove half and
Gauntlet check from you both okay
ready to go
happy
so where you see them now they're at the
1A power
channels are down
okay if you uh gloves The Good the half
is dry and God bless the inside okay
copy ev1 and ev2
so Duke will be having you grab the
cable bag and heading out to one Bravo
koichi you'll be working all of the mli
stuff here in order to reinstall that
pit pin that Duke saw not installed this
is the Locking pin for the telescoping
feature you'll need to peel back the mli
a bit
okay
did it come out
I think we just we're just installing it
here
okay so that's the could you tell me
that where it is
floating
um
correctly opposite of you
okay I think you'll have to peel back to
mli
go back to this MRI yeah yeah he'll open
the top and the bottom and then you'll
be able to see it that's correct and
Duke we'd like you moving out to one
Bravo so we'll have you translate
copy
and I'm just looking at the cables not
the whole bathroom
that's correct you're translating to the
cable bag picking up the one Bravo
cables and heading out to one Bravo
you can see kuichi wakada on the right
side of your screen that is his point of
view uh Nicole Mann identified a pit pin
that had not been installed into the
structure so kuichiwakata is undoing
these levels of multi-layer insulation
to be able to place the pit pin copy
and yeah that lanyard will probably be
at full extension
and if you need to peel back more of the
mli let us know
if you can do a washer check also on
that pin before you install it just make
sure the washer is over the defense
there
and the Fitbit is in you see that on the
head
coffee koichi that looks good we can
close up that Moi again and we'll work
on the mli wire tie install
okay
if this close is completely without the
Fireside that's also fine right
indeed
let me try that again
coming up now on the four hour mark of
the spacewalk during part one of the
spacewalk they completed installation of
a mod kit on the 1B power Channel and
today they were finishing up work on the
1A Channel
Nicole Mann and koichiwakata
successfully routed some cables around
the 1A site again where they've been
spending the majority of their spacewalk
Nicole Mann is now making her way over
to the 1B Channel where they spent their
previous spacewalk to Route some cables
there as well
um I cannot at the moment
um all right let's try to come around
now
looks like it's closed without the wire
tires but I just wanted to make sure
that it's the case
koichi and
position that you need in order to see
the other side of the mli there
there's a little Gap but I think you'll
be able to fix it
okay
and guys big picture update for you
we're at pet of four hours on the nose
for about 45 minutes down on the
timeline right now
so we're going to be prioritizing doing
those one Bravo cables that Duke is on
her way out to do we'll have a modified
version of the apfr shuffle we're still
working that plan and then we do still
intend to grab the P6 apfr
okay copy that
we've got plenty of pet time from a
consumable standpoint we're at about 7
45 there just for your FYI
yes
looking good
I can you update us on kalichi's suit
data it's exactly what we're talking
right now so after analyzing the data it
looks like it was just a blip in the
sensor data but we are happy with the
suit
good to continue
awesome okay good news and my tcv is set
to six
copy tcv6
here on the ground NASA astronaut Xena
Cardman just gave a big picture overview
of our spacewalk she talked about the
pet or the phased elapsed time this is
the total time that they've been
spacewalking with their suits on battery
power which is a little over four hours
with their remaining time Nicole man is
indeed going to continue routing cables
at the 1B power Channel
kawichiwakata is indeed going to move
the portable foot restraints around
remember one of them had a little bit of
a sticky knob on the that control the
pitch function when moving around from
side to side they're working a plan now
on how to go about that without adding
the
make sure that it's okay
copy great news
and previously koichiwakata noticed a
spike in his O2 data
ground teams here in Mission Control
ran all of their data looked at
everything including a suit check of
kuichi wakada's suit and they've been
monitoring the data in the meantime
xenocardmond did relay to the crew that
they have seen no abnormalities again
and are confident that it was just a
little blip in the data
okay
all right koichi
we are waiting on confirmation from all
the interested parties here but we will
have you do a hecka scan as well
okay
let me check that
I don't know if you can see it oh
okay no problem I will do that because
again now copy quiche and we will
actually have you install that wire tie
we think we see a gap in the mli
right okay
okay
looks like it's just not long enough
then let me uh do the Wi-Fi first
yeah we agree with that Gucci let's get
that wire tie on there and then we'll
have you head over to the mounting
bracket for a better vantage point for
your hekka scan
okay
off
crazy and I have the cables
and I am headed out to one Bravo copy
Duke
you'll be crossing the Keel pin and the
apfr going to the non-radiator shop
and then outboard to s5s6
foreign
so we'll have you head over to the
mounting bracket and we'll get a really
good heck of scan
moving right down the to-do list here
you can see NASA astronaut Nicole Mann
on the bottom of your screen she's got
the legs with the red stripes she's
holding a bundle of cables and she's
going to make her way out to the 1B
power Channel where her she spent a lot
of time in her previous spacewalk she
just routed the cables here at the
workshop site that she's at 1A and now
she's making her way over to 1B
the space station just experienced an
orbital Sunset as you can just see it
just got a lot darker on your screen
at the mountain bracket
showing the other side great we're
taking a look that looks good
okay
all right
another is covering everything looking
good koichi give us just a moment will
everybody analyzes
okay
okay can we see the upper triangle looks
great if we could have you dipped below
that mounting bracket and take a look at
the mid strut and try to get the mid
strut in your heck of you
puppy
copy that
that's a good position we're checking on
The View koichi
okay
because you know how the Beyond just uh
fighting with this adult coming apart
here
copy Duke take the time that you need to
get everything in a good config minimize
the snag hazards
and do what works best for you but you
can also put that Cable Bundle around
your brt and help tend it toward your
body
so
good for my BLT then I run them around
the brt but
um
on the floor
no problem Duke
let's have you take a look at the left
side Midfield
okay I'm pointing at the left side
all right a little further left with
your pan there kuichi
we'll take one last look
a little further left
a little bit further so that we can see
the full left side in your heck of you
that's better
okay
I need to go any further
all right Gucci we're happy with that
heck of scan
and with that you can head back around
the Mac canister and you'll be picking
up the TBA bag from the long handrail
copy that
on the left of your screen you can see
the point of view of NASA astronaut
Nicole Mann hey I am
she's got a bunch of cables in her hands
and she's making her way to the 1B work
site for some cable routing
okay
but then I just wanted to double check
with you that the
Anri that I uh that's the you know it
covers the uh
the Uber number cable as well
it's okay right
checking quiche
yeah kuichi we're good without config
okay great all right thank you that I'm
going to translate to the DVA bag and
spell it perfect yep you'll be picking
up that TBA bag bringing it to the cable
bag and stowing it
happy
ass
two one two five I'm gonna take a
right-hand turn
copy right hand turn it two one two five
eight two one three eight we'll be
following along
two one three eight is a good handrail
we track you going over the A-frame to
the non-radiator side
ah
okay I am over and now I'm at it uh
making a left turn headed upwards
so that's
2003.006 from a green hook hey firm two
zero zero six for the green hook
these numbers that you're hearing Nicole
man communicate with the ground are sort
of visual markers um handrail numbers
that are listed on the outside of the
space station that help us know where
she is
in relation to the outside of the space
station as she moves on her way to the
1B power Channel
hey uh I mean I picked up the TV Advance
on my way to the people that
night it's uh
visible in your translations from the
long hand rail to this
greater side to the cable bag there's a
handrail on the
BGA at the bottom right
checking Gucci
foreign
[Applause]
ERS on the move they have completely
installed what they set out to do today
install the mid-strut and lower strut
completing the support structure that
they've been working on and now they're
moving on to some get ahead tasks
okay copy dude I'm gonna take a look at
it
copy
and while you're taking a look at that
just a reminder some cautions for you
are to minimize loads into the wire ties
and mli that are on that handrail 2008
and don't translate on the radiator base
handrails
everybody
okay no it's good I'm just gonna put it
early down here then
foreign
copy Duke
okay
you can Stow the TBA bag in the cable
bag
see that
Duke once you've got that green hook in
place you'll be heading outboard to S6
the outboard non-radiator corner
okay
um headed straight out and I've got the
greenhouse on 2006.
copy
um
[Music]
in the cable bag
okay I'm just uh
copy that
copy quiche
so uh
anything else that I can put it in the
cable bag other than the
be a bag you can also clean up that
GoPro that you put out
okay we'll do that
foreign
aut Nicole Mann is making her way out to
the 1B power Channel
they were at the 1A site that's where
they spent the majority of their space
walking time today thus far the majority
of the four hours and four and a half
hours that they've spent out there you
can see one a kind of towards the top of
your screen there and the yellow she's
making her way now to 1B just so you
kind of get a visualization of where
she's going
okay then I'm at the uh let's start on
the right side
I'm gonna head out and put the scoop
down on the mountains record
copy
ah
okay uh being our cable back is closed
and I put in the TDA can also GoPro
okay copy that's great news
koichi for you once you're ready you'll
be retrieving the apfr and with X from
with 25 and putting it on your brt
translating into the starboard seat of
what
do that
awesome
I'm working on the apfi retrieval
you have to pick it up okay gotcha
taking a look at your screen the points
of view from our astronauts on the right
side koichiwakata is retrieving a
portable foot restraint
meanwhile on the left okay guys big
picture update for you both here Duke
once you have that scoop installed we're
actually going to have you wire tie the
Cable Bundle to the mounting bracket
similar to what you guys did on the last
Eva
just get it sucked to the mounting
bracket as best you can low profile
we're at about four and a half hours pet
and so we're looking at a very modified
apfr uh reconfig here we'll have kuichi
bring that sticky apfr back to the
seated cart
and then Duke will have you meet koichi
at the seated carts and we'll make a
plan from there
but we will not be having you go further
outward after that most likely we'll be
working on a plan
yeah we also sorry to clarify
and then we could talk about cables
perfect
so yeah we won't be having you go
outboard starboard again but we do want
to prioritize that P6 apfr
give it to copies
those words from NASA astronaut and Xena
Cardman up to our space walking
astronauts Nicole man has brought out
her Cable Bundle out to the 1B work site
rather than doing what she did at the 1A
work site and kind of routing them and
wire tying them neatly instead she's
going to take the whole bundle and keep
it in place there for future
spacewalkers to work on at another time
meanwhile they do indeed want
koichiwakata to Stow that portable foot
restraint that gave them trouble during
the last spacewalk onto a seatacart
ceter cart meaning crew equipment
translation Aid cart it's essentially an
equipment Locker an area outside of the
space station where they can store spare
parts that looks great in your heck of
you so we'll have to just use one of the
integral wire ties that's already on the
Cable Bundle and use that to help tend
the cable to the mounting bracket
let's see can I just put either end to
the um because there's only a
wirefighter I think that'll be more
expeditious
okay let's do
hey firm Duke we're good with that plan
please and I picked up
I read it to the uh
Defender
and then I picked up the brt
I'm gonna Translate
copy kuichi you'll be heading inboard to
the starboard Cedar cart
some more directional cues though going
inboard or towards the center of the
International Space Station
let me adjust the TCB a little bit
you know
db2 TCP switch from five to six
coffee tcv6
wakata on the move once again or do you
want me to Route it at the proper
location with the Buffy mark
yeah if you can get that wire tie on the
Sharpie Mark that would be ideal
okay yeah I think that's easy enough
perfect
is in possession of that apfr that
portable foot restraint and is on his
way to that cedar cart where he can stow
it copy that
okay I see uh Dukes faced each other so
I'm going above it pretty good
copy koichi
we're in a brief Communications hand
over here in Mission Control we expect
to get our video back shortly we're
still able to hear the crew at this time
three Clips on the left
foreign
as we come out of this Handover period
and we regain our video it'll slight
we'll get a slightly better view when
we're back as the International Space
Station is beginning to enter an orbital
daytime we expect that pretty shortly
here
okay uh
I'm at the answer point
and I'm going to translate continue to
the
covered video card
copy koichi I'm with you for a few
minutes uh it sounds good we're
following along
great
I was going good
I just got my three twists on the lower
right for the cables and it looks like
they're
coming up okay got a pretty here on the
very end of the station very nice
I'm translating towards the US dollar
theater part now with the with an APR
IL extensions okay if you're happy with
these cables I'm gonna
umichi if you agree
yeah dude we're happy with that plan and
uh please pick up the cable bag on your
way in uh to meet up with uh koichi
okay
[Music]
I'm going to do with one
that's affirmative still the with x in
starboard seated with number one and
I'll give you the numbers when you're
ready
if you're just joining us you're
watching a space walk outside of the
International Space Station with our
space Walkers koichiwakata and Nicole
Mann we are about four hours 38 minutes
in to our spacewalk today the main
objective finish construction of the 1A
irosa mon kit so what does this mean
well the International Space Station is
undergoing some power upgrades
including adding some rollout solar rays
they roll out like a rug sort of on top
of the existing rigid regular arrays
that have been there for a while
it's but these rollout solar arrays are
very powerful they're very efficient so
even though they're kind of overlaying
the top of the rigid arrays it's
actually going to result in more power
generation but before these solar arrays
can be installed
um the astronauts need to do some
construction outside of the space
station we call them mod kits it's
consists of six struts and a mounting
bracket that these solar panels can sit
on
and that's what they've completed today
they began their tasks back in January
20th and Nicole Mann okay we're ready to
copy for the uh setting yep Nicole
Manning okay so are you looking for
Ouija have completed its construction
today they're also doing some additional
tasks
um Nicole man just brought some cables
out to the 1B power Channel
and koichi is working on bringing an a
sticky portable foot restraint
of one
okay 11 and Alpha
okay you don't o'clock
okay does not engage on the
Luigi yeah we see we've seen your hacker
it was 2006 picking up my Greenhouse
copy Duke
because you know any suggestions it
looks like it's uh
in but uh
completely in
okay copy koichi yeah it looks in but I
also see the locking collar is not black
on black
if it helps you can take it out and go
in with a little bit more Force
oh it looks black on black in your
headphones yeah
yeah okay I see a lot of black
protests and good Twitter
okay looks like it's an outstanding
confirm
yeah it looks good in your happy to me
okay so if you've got that okay set at
11 Alpha and an extension of one then we
are good on the with x
okay Alpha
on the right of your screen koichiwakata
his point of view he's at the seat of
cart right now you see the word Sita too
you can continue and he's in the process
of stowing the portable foot restraint
it looks like he got it connected again
it's kind of just a locker where you can
keep spare parts and retrieve them as
needed outside of the space station
ah
and just to remind you since I'm picking
up where Drew left off here Duke you'll
be picking up that cable bag as well
okay
2003 I'm crossing over
copy Duke
okay uh with uh zero one eleven o'clock
bits of alpha uh ranks of one on a beef
extender complete
perfect you will now roll and yaw the
apfr you're going to pop a pop-up box
six and clocking should still be 12.
koichiwakata now at the cedar cart
maneuvering the portable foot restraint
um that xenocarbon had requested
foreign
finished construction of a support
structure that will house on irosa or
roll out solar array launching later
this summer they've totally completed
construction this was at the 1A powered
Channel and during their previous
spacewalk they completed work on the 1B
power Channel
uh just before this kuichiwakada had
completed the cleanup of some
multi-layer insulation putting a pit pin
back in there closing up the insulation
getting it nice and protected against
the elements of space
right now not on screen Nicole Mann is
wrapping up bringing some cables out to
the 1B power Channel
here right on your screen is working on
a articulating portable foot restraint
on the S4 side of the space station
foreign
this task that he's doing here sets them
up in a good position
for the irosa
installation so the solar panels won't
be launched until this summer and when
they're ready to be installed this
portable foot restraint is already in a
good position for them to use during
that installation
okay yeah
on the hdfr complete with the English
State tucked in okay copy papa papa papa
fox six that's a great config
you head to the Anchor Hooks and be
ready to meet Duke when she arrives
there with the cable bag
we'll have her pass off the cable bag to
you and you can take it to the airlock
okay
so I think I'm gonna have to go back
around
forward and the crossover then go out
for die yeah if you agree I do agree
juice yep
and big picture koichi once you get that
cable bag and take it to the airlock
Duke we're gonna have you head out to P6
for that P6 apfr
and then koichi you can head back out
and we'll have you do the Ingress Aid
swap
great puppy
our space Walkers work together in
support of building that support
structure and then went their separate
ways to do their own tasks the
spacewalkers are now working to meet up
together again
[Applause]
the hook
copy both
Christina can I make the soup here at
the anchor okay hey from koichi yeah
we'll have you hang out there Duke's on
her way with the cable bag okay
see that kuichi has reached his
Rendezvous point and Nicole Mann is
making his way over to him to hand
koichiwakata cable back
so I just want to double check if you're
okay with that
unnecessary dude
okay
yeah
just to confirm are you seeing a
different clocking on the scoop or are
you thinking it may have come on
I haven't moved
so
then I was second guessing myself
so I can take a look at it now or if you
want to just make a note when they come
out this summer yeah we'll make a note
do you think you can see it from where
you are just to get eyes on and verify
that it's actually locked I know I wrote
that I couldn't tell I mean it looks
like it's lost but
uh the one that one I did it outboard I
thought it was locked and I could pull
the defend out and it was over but then
I pushed it a little more and it got
like this you know like that little
satisfying click but I don't recall from
this one so that's why I was second
guessing
okay Duke on second thought we will have
you go up and just double check
okay
um I'm Gonna Leave it back here then
since like oh that was a brt on it
yep
I mean by your
should I get the cable bag
uichi let's have you grab the cable bag
actually
well Duke does that double check and
then you can bring the cable bag to the
airlock
okay
all right sounds good
this is a bit of a delicate dance as
koichiwakata makes his way over to
Nicole man to grab a cable bag as you
can imagine there each have several
tethers connecting them to the
International Space Station and they
certainly don't want to get tangled
not fair leaders okay thanks for the
heads up
Houston confers
and let's just have you pause for one
moment before Duke gets on the mod kit
we'll need to have crew get off of
exercise equipment
a firm kuichi you can translate and just
be extra cautious of Duke's safety
tether it is coming away uh from
structure toward her so your feet are
running over top of it right now I
recommend getting a fair lead on it if
you can
okay I
don't see it inside
and I see that
copy
once koichiwakata has that cable bag
he's gonna make his way over to the
airlock where the spacewalk began today
and stow it temporarily
ass
all right Duke you're good to go
let's get eyes on that scoop as fast as
we can
all right I'm continuing
and koichi just
watch out for that tether you're going
back and forth underneath Duke safety
tether right now
guys go to uh play Elite on the two two
one three or two two one four
koichi I think the best plan of action
is for you to back out the way you came
we're concerned about safety tethers and
a big tangle here we're at about five
hours t-e-t so we want to avoid any
safety tester crosses copy that
copy that so uh Duke's feathers should
be basically full review together right
yeah you are over Duke's tether and now
you are also under Duke's tether so
you'll have to come back from underneath
to each other
in order to cross back over along the
cedar rail
we'll keep an eye on it
okay I'll come back to underneath
the scoop is good thanks for letting me
double check that
if it's going to help with save each
other routing I could come down the
right side of the market
which have you stand by there I think
actually having you head back down the
way you came is the best course of
action could we choose just about free
of your safety tether now
okay okay
that'd be great
okay I am approaching the crossing point
copy squishy
okay so uh
can I keep coming back to the Anchor
Point that's perfect okay now we're good
at that okay I'm clear we like you there
let's have you just pause there for a
moment and you can get back in a normal
body orientation Duke you can come off
of the mod kit now grab the cable bag
and we'll have you both head and board
sorry for the shuffle there okay
no problem
relax
actually this orientation is better for
67 monitoring so I will say this
orientation
thank you yeah it's good it's good and
it's clear
about me
relative to my seats
on your left side and now
it's between now it's on your right uh
right side
it should be on my right side so
yeah it's on your right right side and
now it's getting there okay guys in the
middle we're happy with the safety
tether routing at this point koichi we
can have you actually head back in board
to the Anchor Hooks and we'll have Duke
do the cable bag pass off there
okay I'll go back to that go hook
okay sorry about that
um
okay
sounds good
the left of your screen in Nicole man's
point of view you can see the cable bag
that we're talking about she's going to
hand it off to koichi so he could go
bring it to the airlock
don't be Gucci we'll have you just hang
out there for a moment and Duke will
meet you with the cable back okay and
then we'll have you heading inboard
first
I'll see that
okay I've got the bag on my VRT just
releasing infrastructure and I'll be
right there freaky okay
and after that I can go
through the analog to install the cable
bag is that right hey firm can we have
you stole that cable bag in the airlock
and then you can pop back out of the
airlock you'll put down a waste tether
and lock that waist tether and then
we'll work the slingshot cleanup
okay all right they'll come back to the
uh
negative not yet we'll have to clean up
the slingshot first so just get back to
the airlock and you'll put your waste
tether on the airlock during extender
Stow that crew lock the cable bag in the
crew lock
and then we'll have some further
instructions for cleaning up the
slingshot
okay please okay
now five hours into the spacewalk
Nicole Mann is in the process of handing
koichiwakata a cable bag it's not as
simple as just handing it over you can
see they're on different planes there
koichi had to move one of his anchor
hooks to be able to receive it and move
over to the airlock earlier in our
coverage we described these anchor hooks
kind of like rock wall climbing you have
your ropes tied to one Central Point up
at the top but you're still free to move
up down all around
so he had to reset his anchor hook in
order to move to the airlock Nicole Mann
had to do the same thing but also moving
the cable back from where it was stowed
onto her body restraint tether and now
over to koichiwakata
do that you yeah
do that
all right you ready for me to give you
this table back I'm ready
tell us up my rut to it
okay
I will first read it
okay thread it you can let it go I can
release it okay
thank you
before you take off good to you
okay
don't let me get that CRT to that
they're handing over the bags now
and there's the bag floating just above
our spacewalkers there
clothes
okay
all right
hey it's better yeah
they saved each other it's been good
I'm gonna translate today hello okay
yeah you look good okay copy all guys
and with that we'll give you a big
picture update here so we're just over
five hours pet we have plenty of
consumables looking at uh about a 740
pet based on consumables at this point
so you're doing great
what we could do is work the P6 apfr
retrieval that would put us at about
seven hours pet if that all goes
smoothly
there's always a chance as you come back
outboard to just pause and not go all
the way out to P6 or if you make it to
P6 you can always drop off that apfr
early in order to head inboard more
quickly so we'll just be looking for
your thoughts on that plan koichi while
Duke does the P6 apfr retrieval you
could be working the Ingress Aid swap on
the seated carts so we'll just take your
thoughts on how you're feeling in terms
of energy management and everything
about that plan
um yeah I'll head out to P6 and grab
that apfo and understand that I can
break out
uh really at any point if uh if for some
reason it's going wrong
it works for me what do you think kaliki
yeah for me the uh seems to be good then
the translation
seems to be a good idea
okay perfect we copy all
so koichi will continue inboard
get that cable bag in the airlock get
your waste tether hooked up to the
airlock d-ring extender we'll clean up
the slingshot and as we work that we
still have time to just send you both to
the airlock or for other get ahead tasks
but for now that's our plan
copy that
and with words from Xena Cardman our
spacewalkers now have their marching
orders
for the rest of the spacewalk we're
about five hours in so far but for the
remainder akuichiwakata is gonna go drop
off a cable bag and then swap out some
Ingress AIDS Ingress AIDS are referring
to our portable foot restraints kind of
something that helps you get into these
portable foot restraints he's going to
swap out the Ingress aid for those
meanwhile Nicole man is making her way
to the far end of the space station P6
the port six truss to retrieve a
portable foot restraint herself and just
bring it a little bit closer for a
future for a future spacewalk
ah
okay I'm at the end up
putting up the thermal cover
copy kuichi
you can get your waste tether on the
airlock during extender gate closed lock
on block
do you work
okay my best place better
this is now attached to air maximum
extender take closer block
okay
and we'll get a check also of the other
end of that waste tether the small hook
on your suit during extender okay so
that's
Okay small Hook is attached to my left
leaving extender get close hooked up
black
perfect
okay koichi with your go duke can start
cleaning up
Duke for you that would be released
you'll release kuichi's ev2 anchor Hook
from 3011
stow it on your waste tether with the
gate closed hook lock on block
okay I have a right to easy to Anchor
hook
and removing any two hooks
copy
so you'll get that on your waist tether
with both of the hooks closed locked
black on black
confirm you can get that cable lock
cable bag in the airlock
okay I have easy two tanker hook
attached to my right
foreign
copy and we'll check for your small hook
as well on your waist tether that it is
locked black on black as well
koichiwakata in the airlock now stowing
the cable bag he just retrieved from
Nicole Mann
[Music]
okay copy Duke with that you can get
your ev1 anchor Hook from handrail 3217
and stow it on your mini Workstation
foreign
copy Duke you can head inward
ah
so you heard some chatter with Nicole
Mann with our ground IVs in a Cartman
today here on the ground she's
configuring her hooks to be in a
position to go out to the far reaches of
the space station the port 6 truss to
retrieve a portable foot restraint
foreign
a Coleman interview now
[Music]
copy great work kuichi we'll have you
hang out there we still need your waste
tether locked to the airlock during
extender well Duke is resetting those
anchor hooks
and I'll be continuing along you're
going to be looking for mile marker
81.90
for those new anchor hook locations
that'll be on s0
and koichiwakata has successfully stowed
the cable bag back into the airlock
foreign
[Applause]
just over five hours and 15 minutes in
today's space walk with NASA astronaut
Nicole Mann and Japanese astronaut
konichiwakara
Nicole Mann is currently resetting some
anchor hooks
quick hand over here guys
so these anchor hooks were initially set
when heading to the mod kit work sites
for the first half of the installation
of this mod kit now they need to reset
them to a different location in order
for Nicole man to reach the port side to
grab the portable foot restraint
portable foot restraint from the port 6
Truss
even though we're needing to reset the
anchor hooks right now in order for
Nicole man to get to where she is to the
P6 truss
after that it's not necessary to reset
them on her way back as they can reach
the airlock from the port side anchors
okay perfect Duke yep just Nader of mile
marker 8190 you're looking for a zero
handrail 3530
Tennessee three five three zero
and you'll be putting your ev1 anchor
hook on three five three zero
okay my 81 anchor Hook is on three five
three zero this flow sliders velocity
perfect next you can attach koichi's ev2
anchor hook to handrails three five
three one that's just Zenith of mile
marker 8190.
82 anchor Hook is on a three five three
one
it's called flight is locked and black
on black
guppy Duke
with that kuichi you can release your
waste tether
and get the thermal cover closed
you'll be heading back to the cedar
cards
okay
Duke next for you you'll be continuing
outboard translating to the apfr in P6
with 17.
okay
get all cleaned up here
and Nicole Mann is on the move after
completing another item on her checklist
of resetting these anchors again these
anchors were originally set as a way to
get them to the 1A work site where they
were working on this mod kit this
support structure that they've been
building for these two spacewalks but in
order for her to do this task of going
out to the port 6 truss at the far end
of the space station to retrieve this
portable foot restraint they needed to
reset these anchors put them in a
different position so she could get out
there outboard on face one crossing the
sarge and dropping your green hook at P4
handrail 511
foreign
perfect
and there's Nicole man on your screen
now making her way out
meanwhile kuichiwakata is still at the
airlock the cable bag he was working
with is properly stowed and now he's
working to close the thermal cover of
the airlock
okay see now thermal cover is closed I'm
going to translate back to Stubborn okay
copy sounds great
wow
I'm here five dollars are down
copy goblets down
all right can you give me that
Greenhouse again
that's gonna be P4 handrail five one one
one
okay I'm there welcome my Greenhouse
guppy
because you know the uh
with this job is from the one that I
installed to
you're going to be grabbing the
ingression
from that sticky apfr that you brought
inboard and transferring it to another
apfr that's also on the starboard seated
cart it's in with four okay I see that
okay I see that
green hawk is down
copy green hook Duke next you'll be
crossing over the iea to the
non-radiator side
and at the outboard non-radiator Edge
you'll continue outboard
workflow I'm not yet I don't see a
radiator I'm headed off work but Andrew
that's a good handrail Duke
koichi once you get the Ingress Aid you
can take the wire tie from the Ingress
Aid and sew it in your trash bag and
then you'll install it on the apfr and
with with four it being the Ingress AIDS
copy that
[Applause]
okay before that I will
attach my wreck to the English
happy koichi
kuichi will take a glove happen Gauntlet
check from you
okay
that's that's good no change and have to
try and gauntlets are in place
copy all thanks koichi
the speedo card double keto cards
yes ma'am
that's correct so you're going to set
that yaw to three
all three okay
and we'll take a glove half and Gauntlet
check from you as well Duke
baby ones gloves are good top is dry as
long as it down copy all dude thanks
of three
okay
copy you can retrieve that apfr and stow
it on your brt
and then I retrieved the uh
foreign
copy Duke
oh this has an English let me get that
cleaned up first
earlier
getting live views of Mission Control
here
under the direction of flight director
Chloe Mary she's Consulting with the
spacewalking team behind her from a
quick handle getting the rest of the
tasks planned out for this spacewalk we
are five hours and 30 minutes in
Nicole man has reached her destination
at the P6 truss again quite far away
from the center of the space station to
retrieve a portable foot restraint she
has it in tow and is now making her way
back this just helps future space
Walkers not have to take the time to
have to go out there during their
spacewalk really setting us up for
success for the next one
to translate back
like this I believe gotta collapse which
is not bend it down then when I stick it
in the whip
all these brothers below it
copy Duke that makes sense to me
I'll just go slow I'm aware that it's
gonna stick out more than normal
glass
we've got our live views back on the
left of your screen you've seen as
astronaut Nicole man with that portable
photo strength
different
people in the starboard but I just
said creature mercado's also setting
future spacewalkers up for success
he's taking an Ingress Aid of a portable
purpose
that apfr whenever you need we're at
about a pet of 540.
okay doing good right now fortunately
it's not a bad translation but um
so this guy doesn't swing too much or
maybe take it slow copy all Duke I like
that plan you did a great job with that
translation
okay it is attached to black on black
good pull test good twitch bet
I'm gonna put that's the new Vaya Thai
the
if I understood copy koichi that's a
good plan
you can see wakata on your screen now
installing a short wire tie on the
Ingress Aid this Ingress great Aid goes
onto the portable foot restraint kind of
helps the spacewalkers get their feet
into it
ass
[Applause]
ume
foreign
work both of you we've got plenty of
time just being nice and deliberate as
we get you both back in board and
cleaned up
bounce it sounds good
as our spacewalkers complete their last
tasks of the day before cleaning up
their work sites and heading back into
the airlock for a job well done if you
have any questions about what you've
been seeing today go ahead and put your
question on social media using ask NASA
and we'll do our best to answer on air
yeah
okay I'm still in this double card
copy you both
and Duke you'll be installing the wire
tie on the AIA
copy koichi great work
Duke for you you'll be heading back to
that P4 iea
once you're on the inboard edge of the
p4iea cross over to the radiator side
and pick up your green hook
thank you
we got one question on YouTube about
when these iroses the rollout solar
arrays will be launching so remember
that for every irosa or solar array that
we're adding to the space station that
has to have a counterpart it's mounting
bracket that attaches it to the outside
of the space station so in today's space
walk we did install that mounting
bracket to the 1A power Channel and soon
it'll get paired with an irosa and to
answer that question on YouTube the
irosa will be launching on a SpaceX
cargo Dragon vehicle during the SpaceX
28 the 28th Commercial resupply Services
Mission and that'll be launching
sometime this summer
foreign
it underneath the AP bar
copy that's perfect and after that looks
like the Ingress 8 has already tucked
pretty low profile
okay I didn't get your last but
English it is already touched
in
we got another another question this
time from Twitter from Mike Washington
who asked about the total duration of
the spacewalk where 5 hours and 43
minutes in so far our spacewalk began at
6 45 a.m central time we expect it to go
up to seven hours pictures of the sticky
apfr
if you could just get some eyes on get
some good photos see what you can see
yeah maybe we'll discover something
about that sticky pitch
copy that
okay
Duke great work
Luigi for you if you see anything that
looks like an mmod strike
obviously make sure to keep your hands
well clear of it don't touch that area
and we'll take photos
okay do you have any specific areas that
you're interested
well this is that a pitch knob area or
everywhere
the pitch joint especially and if you
see anything obvious let us know
okay copy that
this is at night and it's uh I see uh
you know light from external life
survival writing to take pictures but so
try to take pictures as much as they can
copy that's no problem Gucci yeah we'll
just snag a couple photos and then we'll
have you head inboard to the airlock
and stay ahead of Duke there
okay
let's double see that
okay taking pictures here then
you can see spacewalker koichi wakata
there acting as photographer he's
documenting this sticky uh portable foot
restraint pitch joint uh gave them some
trouble during the last spacewalk so
he's getting documentation so our ground
teams can take a better look at it
as koichiwakata documents the sticky
portable foot restraint I want to take
another question from Twitter this time
from MK9 who asked what are the next
steps for the irosa solar array upgrades
is it 4A and 4B channels remaining to
have their solar array deployed
so I want you to take a look at this
graphic here kind of shows what we've
done so 4A and 4B that MK9 mentions in
his or her tweet it's already completed
has mounting bracket and has solar array
four are done
3A 4A 2B and 4B are already deployed
we've completed the mounting hardware
for one a and one B all that's left is
for them to get iroses themselves roll
out solar arrays so to answer the
question one a and one B are next up to
get the irosa solar base apfr
okay
and correction on that clocking dupe
that's eight not nine
yes eight thank you
foreign
a while ago Nicole Mann set out to
travel out to the port 6 truss of the
International Space Station to grab a
articulating portable foot restraint she
has grabbed it and made her way to a
cedar cart a cedar cart being a sort of
stowage locker to the outside of the
International Space Station where they
can kind of keep and store things as
they need it and now she's working on
stowing it onto the scene card make sure
that the Ingress Aid isn't going to be
in the way or anything on structure will
be in the way of you installing and then
holding down that aggressive
okay you got it
here with two getting off my CRT though
yeah I'm still trying to go to the other
side of the 185 for the next short
coffee Gucci no problem we've got a
great camera view of you looking good
us
you're getting live views from both of
our space walking astronauts we're
Midway through an orbital night time
outside of the International Space
Station as it flies over the coast of
Somalia it looks like eggs
later then I'll be able to uh hold it
down
and koichi if you check
standby
Gucci we were tracking a possibly a wire
tie that may have come out of your trash
bag not sure if you have eyes on
it
still
[Applause]
I cannot open the
trash bag
yeah copy no problem we'll check the
video koichi where do you see it
we saw it on the video we think we'll
check the video we'll find it out you
might be able to feel the soft fabric
portion of your trash bag and see if the
wire tie is still in there but we'll
check the video no problem
and I can feel
that I'm by a type
of looking thing instead of trash bag I
can't feel it through the glove
I think
copy
it's really yeah it's really difficult
to tell
yeah no problem we'll check the video
koichi
okay and uh okay
other pictures on the other side of The
Big Short
any other areas
checking
okay Gucci we're good with pictures on
that apfr
so we can have you we'll have you guys
coordinate we'll take your thoughts on
whether Duke thinks it might be helpful
to have a second crew member over there
for that sticky Ingress Aid
okay uh
okay rather that I'll go to the uh the
fourth side
yeah so I got it um
it unfortunately has been nine so I just
need to repop it over to eight and then
I can get on that ingressa
okay
copy and Duke are you seeing any
possible interferences
um no actually it looks okay maybe I'll
try it right now let me let me try right
now
I need this helps so I am black on black
I've got a good full twist Paul copy do
you find the apfr
yeah I already uh head that way okay
it was just difficult so this is working
out fine okay great
a firm that would be great yep
okay Xena do you want me to translate
your dialogue or to
we'll have you head to the airlock and
get connected on the airlock hearing
extender
great
okay
copy Duke nice work
great
foreign
we'll have Duke do that on her way in so
you can head to the airlock
okay
for come coming up right on pet of six
hours you guys are doing great
this is Mission Control Houston live
with coverage of our space walk today
we're nearing the six hour mark
our space Walkers are wrapping up their
tasks for the day
copy Duke
I mixed I messed up some of the uh
what are the other settings I know
fox.fox I think it's 12 and three it'll
be papa papa Fox 3.
uh
okay and that's that box
okay
Houston likes that plan just take it
nice and smooth we'll get you back in
the airlock and then Duke you'll follow
that sounds good
I'm coming down on this bird
copy guichi
ah
NASA astronaut koichiwakata making his
way back into the airlock
I'm gonna open up the uh
normal color copy thermal cover once
you've got that open you can take your
waste tether to the airlock during
extender and Gates closed locked black
on black
work
[Applause]
foreign
copy no problem Duke
okay uh be nice
I left waited to the air of the Union
Contender it closed two clocks black and
black on the small hook on my left right
there is attached to my left ear and
extend the gate close to clock back on
black
copy all that's a great config we'll
have you hang out there for just a
moment
okay
copy
okay I am back at the anchors
copy Duke
okay Duke we've got a good load path
through koichi you can Rhett to kuiji's
Anchor hook that's on handrail 3531
and move it to your waste other and
we'll look for both hooks gate close
block on block
now six hours into our space walk today
our space Walkers wrapping up they're
getting ready to Ingress or get into the
air lock
earlier this morning at 6 45 they
Ingress to now they're going back into
the airlock to complete their spacewalk
anchor
copy Duke
Nicole Mann this is her point of view
right now configuring her tethers to
also go inside the airlock
ah
all right I'm too thank you is attached
to my right right way better
four kids clothes the spider over love a
black or black
copy Duke
we'll also have you check the other end
of your waist tether for your small hook
I release my rat to his
copy
you know how much time do we have Before
Sunrise
checking
which you've got about five minutes
until sunrise
okay copy that thank you
can't see it
copy Duke
we're great on time
to be nice and deliberate here
foreign
an external camera on you duke
yeah can you see me
checking not right now we've got your
hecka but I don't think we have a good
external view we'll check
okay okay
copy Duke
let me try something else
the point of view of NASA astronaut
Nicole Mann on your screen now she's
working to commit a figure her tethers
in a way that she can get inside of the
airlock
um it's pretty dark out there right now
but we expect an orbital Sunrise with
some better lighting soon
fast is the problem
copy I understand now
let me see if I can maneuver
copy we do have an external camera view
on you but it's pretty dark and there's
some stuff in the way I unfortunately
don't have a great View
foreign
[Music]
okay is locked I thought I got it
great work Duke
passing the six hour mark on our space
walk today about six hours and 10
minutes as our crew Works to get back
into the airlock just before both Nicole
Mann and kuichi wakata had completed
their tasks
uh duke or Nicole Mann was tasked with
going way out to the port six trust and
retrieving a portable foot restraint
bringing it a little bit closer
copy
meanwhile kawichi of ricotta had
relocated a portable foot restraint from
Ingress Aid swapping it out with another
one
um and put that on its Cedar cart for
future space walking news
and it is so
great work awesome job Duke you can
start translating back to the airlock
reminder to depress the seated cart
brakes you'll press the starboard seated
cart brakes and the port key to cart
breaks two times each on your way in
say something
foreign
camera you can see we're entering
entering an orbital sunrise
this level
copy Duke
astronaut Nicole man is confirming that
the brakes on the seat of cart are fully
engaged after that she's going to Stow
her strut bag if you remember at the
beginning of the Eva they had to bring
out the mid strut to finish installation
so she's stowing the empty bag back into
the airlock before she gets in
foreign
great job Duke and just a heads up right
now your safety tether looks good but
for a moment was about to go between
your legs you're in a great config now
looking good okay
I'm coming down to see the fur okay
I see her
what are we doing on Titan Nina
or at pet 615 doing great
if we take a couple photos before we
suck our go into the crew locks you bet
Duke
all right
perfect lighting
stay there
this time
so let me get my erasers
what's up
okay
another one
another one okay that's great all right
let me get my local channel I got a
couple of you got a good first view in
the background here awesome
traveling really quickly there
we've got another one here
yeah
that's what it was okay
you can see our spacewalker NASA
astronaut Nicole man they're with the
camera taking some pictures of koichi
and perhaps of this orbital Sunrise
they're about six hours and 17 minutes
into their spacewalk and have completed
their tasks for the day so taking
advantage of the scenes grabbing a few
shots and then going back into the
airlock
all right
I guess okay
all right let's go ahead
all right let's go in
right then I think I'm gonna Ingrid
coffee great work both of you koichi
before you Ingress you can turn off your
hecka
mark
[Applause]
and koichi since that assembly is a
little bit loose above your head if Duke
needs to help push the button that's
totally fine
yeah that's probably better
could you uh
okay just pushed okay that guy's off
thank you
okay I'm gonna come in
pass
okay I am in
copy kuichi Duke you can also turn off
your hekka and Ingress
[Music]
all right coming in all right I see your
feet no your head first right okay yeah
okay so I think if you just bend your
knees okay
all right
okay
disregard we were going to ask you about
the thermal cover but you answered our
question okay yeah
[Applause]
we're beginning to get our final views
of our space Walkers here you see the
legs of NASA astronaut Nicole Mann she's
there in the pair of legs with the red
stripes making her way into the airlock
here
all right all right I'm in the thermal
cover is closed awesome
got me Duke you can release the hook
from its stowage tether Point attach the
hook to the magnetic plate Deering and
cinch the strap until six lines are
visible on the tail verify that the
magnet is engaged okay
kuichi you can start working on your SCU
while Duke is working on the thermal
cover remove it from its stowage pouch
remove your DCM cover and connect that
to you to your DCM
copy didn't work
copy
livable
copy Duke verify that the magnet is
engaged
and with that you can also start working
on your ICU
a okay
Nicole man chatting with our ground IBS
in a Cardman today about releasing hooks
using d-rings magnets this is all in an
effort to close the hatch thermal cover
this is the outermost part of the hatch
and it looks like she's successfully
completed that step
after that
you just heard kuichiwakada be referred
to as ev2 our ev1 of course today is
Nicole Mann and doing these hatch
operations is part of her
responsibilities as the ev1 max cooling
minimizes the time necessary for Su
Cooling
okay
we're back now with our live views
inside the International Space Station
we have NASA astronaut Frank Rubio one
of our suit IVs today I'm working on my
FCU
copy Duke still working on the TCG
setting
early this morning Frank Rubio helped
our space Walkers into their spacesuits
and today he and Josh cassid are going
to help them out of their spacesuits
after repressurization has begun
copy you both
copy
even though the hatch thermal Club cover
is closed it does not necessarily mean
our hatch is closed and in fact that's
still not expected to happen for several
minutes now
for both of you understand you're still
working the tcv setting but for now
we'll take you take the water switch to
off expect H2O is off message
thank you
kccb is uh
pack of gold or easy bomb and uh for the
switch coming off really too also
copy you both
copy eb2
that water is off for easy ones
copy water off for both of you
hey at this point we've got a two minute
wait
until we can do any further steps
but next we'll be working on the hatch
all right please I'm just gonna maneuver
to get eyes on the hat just need to go
as far as your head as possible okay
it's okay
but this is sometimes I can go to the
port side so I'm gonna go up
and then roll yeah
[Applause]
go the other way
if you're just joining us here are two
space Walkers are just on the other side
of that door having completed uh what's
now been a six hour and 30 minutes
spacewalk and Counting uh they're going
through the steps to close the hatch
behind them so that repressurization can
begin
okay crew you can verify that the outer
hatch is clear of hardware
verify the handle position per hatch
decal and close and lock the hatch
okay it is a clear hardware and
[Music]
[Applause]
yes
be clear
okay
[Applause]
foreign
feedback
okay and then they made okay
[Applause]
NASA astronaut Josh cassida has joined
the equipment lock section of the quest
airlock
you see him there wearing the Hat
speaking to NASA astronaut Frank Rubio
and the bluish black shirt
[Music]
okay crew we are ready for the repress
check that your scu's are connected to
the DCM we've got your water off for two
minutes check that the EV hatch is
closed and locked
is closed in
not very satisfying
quick is it
okay
or does it just flip over
okay just to clarify are you guys closed
and lost talking about the hatch handle
no not the handle the lock but the thing
you flip over it says locked
does it pop into a d10 or it just flips
yeah it sounds like a good config to us
Duke it's not a very noticeable detent
okay on the UIA check oxygen for emu one
and two valves are open
open
switch power for ev1 and 2 on and check
that the Emu LEDs are on
UIA
power two uh on and uh two LEDs are on
check power for ev1 and 2 volts are
between 18 and 19.
certified 18.6 on both
copy 18.6 on both under the hatch is
officially closed and Xena Cardman is
now walking our space walking astronauts
through a
pre-re-pressurization checklist
for this is completed repressurization
can begin
baby why I'm tired I see you
copy ev1n2 on SCU power
on your DCM take your O2 actuator to
press
The View you're seeing now is that of
Mission Control Houston and the
International Space Station's flight
control room
this is a view of all the flight
controllers in the room under the
direction of flight director Chloe
Maring as they're working to get the
spacewalking astronauts ready for
repressurization
copy ev2
copy ev1 and 2 in prep great work both
of you
yeah all right check that the EV hatch
impact is closed
I'm very close
also too
okay ev2 we're actually showing you not
quite impressed just yet if you could
give your O2 actuator a little wiggle
and make sure that it's fully in the
Press detent
okay
I'm jiggling it
and Duke will take a wiggle test from
you as well
oh it's all coming
they Wiggles but still it says the
question marks
oh looks like it's red
82 DCM shows the boat throughout theater
and that threat happy koichi
we see you both in press okay check that
the easy hatch empath is closed
okay
I'm close
IV hatch Equalization valve throttle off
to Norm at your desired rate EV expect
an alert tone
okay and uh Xena I am with you on one
and I will take it from here great job
you've got it over to you Frank
congratulations to you all
and thanks so much to the team for all
the effort you put into the
troubleshooting and all the hours at it
it was a great uh great space and great
procedures that you gave us to get that
unlock installed and Well Done policy
for sticking with it
good job
thank you
thank you to the entire team for the
entire you know that wonderful
procedures and real-time advice for the
troubleshooting it works out great
I'd like to thank uh that's the folks
who are supporting in Houston and in
Cuba uh
um
thank you again
hey guys welcome back great job out
there have you back okay I'll be
throttling the IV hatch valve from off
to Norm let me know if the rate works
well for you
our ground IV Xena Cardman has handed
off her duties of talking to these space
Walkers over to Frank Rubio who's on
your screen now he'll be continuing with
the rest of the steps until they get
their spacesuits off
okay it started let me know if that
works we are going to go up to five and
pause there you should expect an alert
Zone at for PSI
Bobby Bobby
the crew there just shared some kind
words with the team here on the ground
namely thanking them for the
troubleshooting measures happening
between the January 20th spacewalk and
now as they went out today to do some of
the fixes try some new workarounds
and ultimately it led to success
now repressurization has begun as you
can hear that sound in the background
we're going to vacuum a vacuum we
started at about
0.3 PSI and we're steadily moving up
we're gonna do a suit check at 5 PSI
today's space walk concluded when our
space Walkers turned their spacesuits
off of battery power at a time of 1 26
PM Central Time 2 26 PM Eastern bringing
their total spacewalking time to 6 hours
and 41 minutes
foreign
ah
the crew lock is now sitting at just
above 5 PSI where we're doing a planned
hold make sure everything is okay before
continuing back up to the pressure of
the International Space Station and that
of sea level here on Earth of 14.7 PSI
so we're going to wait a minute here
these same steps were followed but in
Reverse during depressurization as they
prepared to get out the door now they're
preparing to get back into the space
station after their spacewalk
all right guys the pressure has been
stable for
um one minute with a Delta of less than
one so for both of you check search you
can go up the heaters off of
offer 81. I'll follow you too
for both of you please check your gloves
for contamination and reports any uh
noticeable abnormalities
great to hear for both of you take your
O2 actuator to IV
y
great job okay I will be throttling the
equalization valve and we're going to go
to a DP DTF zero here let me know how
this works for you
starting now
after entering a momentary hold at 5 PSI
repressurization has begun to continue
ah
all right
[Applause]
foreign
spacewalk began at 6 45 a.m Central Time
ending at 1 26 p.m central time for a
total of 6 hours and 41 minutes let's
take a look at the spacewalk by the
Numbers it was the 259th spacewalk in
support of space station assembly
maintenance and upgrades it was the
second space station spacewalk of 2823
in the sixth spacewalk of expedition 68.
it was the second spacewalk of both
koichiwakata and Nicole man's career
totaling 14 hours and two minutes of
their career space walking time
today's spacewalk again lasted six hours
and 41 minutes
which led to 68 Days 12 hours and 28
minutes of total spacewalking time
[Applause]
these 68 days refer to the total
spacewalking time of all 259 spacewalks
in support of space station assembly
maintenance and upgrades
this year it being the sixth from
Expedition 68 five out of the quest
airlock where our space walking
astronauts are now and one from the
poisk airlock
[Applause]
with the conclusion of the spacewalk
that brings the total space walking
hours of expedition 68 to 41 hours and
51 minutes
repressurization almost complete now
hovering above 13 PSI making its weight
of 14.7
repressurization continues as we
momentarily lost our view of that crew
lock of the quest error lock you're now
seeing the mission control team who
worked on today's operation monitoring
our space Walkers coming up with
troubleshooting Solutions as they worked
to get that mid strut of this mod kit
installed
ah
the man standing at the back of the room
there that's Keith Johnson he knows the
ins and outs of the procedures that we
did today coming up with many of the
solutions and Consulting with his teams
in the back rooms relaying his
data to the road just in front of him
our flight director Chloe Maring and our
ground ivy the person who communicated
all of the instructions with our crew
today Xena Cardman our astronaut
repressurization is complete and the
hatch has been opened
oh God
thank you guys
[Applause]
looks like kuichiwakata are an astronaut
from Japan is the first out of the hatch
new sensation on one you have a go for
step four of one decimal two four zero
foreign
copies thanks Frank
ah
NASA astronaut and Josh cassida you see
there in the Hat in the lower left
corner of your screen with NASA
astronaut Frank Rubio and the short
sleeves and the upper right working now
with spacewalker koichiwakata getting
his safer unit off getting his helmet
off I'm gonna get his gloves off as well
yeah like Houston heads up uh space
Crown one the crew is no longer hot mic
I understand crew is no longer hot bike
thanks so much
this is the quest airlock aboard the
International Space Station what you see
in the foreground here with astronaut
koichiwakata Frank Rubio and Josh
cassida that's what's known as the
equipment lock section of the quest
airlock Nicole Mann you can kind of see
her legs there with the red stripes she
is still in the crew lock she's going to
make her way over to the equipment lock
with the help of our ground excuse me
with the help of our suit IVs here
Nicole man's being helped into the crew
lock now
into the equipment lock now
just like they did with koichiwakata our
suit I've used Frank Rubio and Josh
cassida are working on either side of
our space walker working to remove these
safer units the simplified aid for Eva
rescue
our space Walkers today are wrapping up
they are both inside the hatch they've
re gone undergone repressurization on
our back into the equipment lock with
our suit IVs who are helping them kind
of get out of their suits right now to
recap what they've accomplished today
NASA astronaut Nicole man and Japanese
astronaut koichi wakata successfully
installed a mod kit this is a necessary
step to set the stage for the delivery
of the next set of irosas or roll out
solar arrays on spacex's 28th cargo
resupply launch this summer
in an effort to
in an effort to revamp the International
Space Station's power channels give it a
little bit more power with these rollout
Soul surveys
they began work on this structure in
January and completed their installation
today after some teamwork and
collaboration with the team here in
Mission Control
this involved work on a lower and
mid-strut and wrapped up their work by
tightening the bolts today rigidizing
the structure getting it ready for these
irosas they went on to do some work that
could save time for future spacewalkers
including Nicole Mann who delivered a
bundle of cables out to the 1B power
Channel
koichiwakata swapped out an Ingress Aid
on a portable foot restraint that had
some trouble rotating from side to side
now when it's used for the next
spacewalk the user won't have to spend
time swapping it out themselves and
Nicole Mann ventured out to the port 6
truss to bring a different portable foot
restraint closer to the work site for
future spacewalks
we're back with our live views now
kumichiwakata on the left and Nicole
Mann on the right
back with our live views now
Josh casted and now removing the hecka
part of the
straps onto the helmet gives us some
nice high definition views of their
point of view that's wakata that he's
working on on the left
hey Josh there's a flashlight in front
of the camera if you can grab it for us
thank you
Josh cassid and now working to remove
the gloves of Japanese astronaut koichi
picata
it looks like Frank Rubio is doing the
same on the right side to Nicole Mann
and the gloves are off as our suit IVs
NASA astronaut Frank Rubio and Josh
cassida work to get our space Walkers
out of their spacesuits right now of
course having some playful pictures
taken along the way
this photography is also crucial to
documenting this post-spacewalk the
condition of the spacesuits the location
of where they're stowing everything
and the helmets are off on our space
Walkers Nicole Mann on the right and
konichiwakata on the left all smiles all
around
this was their second spacewalk and of
course the second spacewalk of 2023 as
well
their Total Space walking time equals 14
hours two minutes mostly with the goal
of setting up the mod kit on the 1A
power channel of the International Space
Station they previously wrapped up
installing the 1B power Channel as well
finishing the 1A channels a day you
could look to your left and smile real
quick
perfect
excellent family photo there thanks guys
not only did Nicole man and koichiwakata
finish installing this mod kit to set
the stage for future delivery of the
irosa's International Space Station roll
out solar arrays for future power
upgrades but they also did a lot of work
setting the stage for future space walks
bringing in equipment that was farther
away bringing it to the work site for
future spacewalks replacing
sticky portable foot restraints and
Ingress aids with ones that will make
the lives just a little bit easier of
our future spacewalkers
these spacewalkers set their spacesuits
to battery power at 6 45 a.m leading
them to a 6 hour 41 minute space walk to
get these installations complete and
these these tasks to set them up for
success for future spacewalks
thank you for watching and sending in
your questions via ask NASA you can
follow along with Expedition 68's
mission on the International Space
Station blog and on social media that
concludes our coverage today thanks for
watching this is Mission Control Houston
[Music]